today we're speaking with Stephen
Bonnell Otherwise Known online as
Destiny he's one of the most outspoken
Millennial political commentators
describes himself as a very big Social
Democrat and is in many ways the
anti-bench Shapiro there are certain
social programs that we should advocate
for in the United States we should have
those social programs and then we should
tax people accordingly today we're
getting a little controversial and
breaking down the fundamental
differences between the left and the
right discussing some of the biggest
problems that are tearing apart America
and the events that caused him to become
more liberal as he began making millions
of dollars as I went from being broke to
making a lot of money I started to
realize like how totally unfair
life was over the past like 12 or 13
years My Views have slowly changed to
being more left-leaning basically we're
also going to be talking about greed
capitalism relationships and toxic
masculinity on this episode of subscribe
that's my line Jack I always say on this
episode okay the point is guys subscribe
like comment thank you so much but first
a word from our sponsor guys we gotta
give a huge thank you to our sponsor
Unbound Mourinho they sent us a bunch of
shirts and I gotta say they're my
favorite shirts I've ever had in my
entire life I still don't think you've
washed it which is a bit of a concern I
have watched it once I've had it for
three weeks but Grim it doesn't smell at
all because it's 100 Merino wool I think
you'd be shocked at just how soft it is
yeah they sent us a whole bunch of stuff
and I have to say it is absolutely
comfortable I just wear it all the time
because it feels like pajamas but it
doesn't look like pajamas I've played
pickleball in it gone on walks and even
worn it to the gym and it still smells
like it did when I first put it on
that's because Merino wool is incredibly
light moisture wicking and odor
resistant not only is their clothing
super practical but it also looks really
good unlike other performance clothing
Unbound Merino offers both exceptional
quality and style all of that makes
Zumba Marina the perfect choice for
traveling with which I'll certainly be
doing from every trip I take from here
on out so whether you're an avid
traveler or a busy entrepreneur Unbound
Merino can help you pack less and
embrace the freedom of a minimalist
lifestyle I'm a firm believer in quality
over quantity and you give me like three
of these shirts and I will be set for
life I don't need anything else so check
out unboundmerino.com I think you're
going to be super happy with your
clothing I know we are so if you're
interested and it helps with the podcast
a lot feel free to use the link Down
Below in the description and use the
code iced coffee for 10 off your first
purchase the link again down below it
also really does help support this
podcast it would mean so much thank you
Unbound Marino and on to the episode hey
guys welcome back to the iced coffee
hour my name is Destiny and we're gonna
be arguing about why hot chocolate is
better than iced coffee for the next two
hours
cheese so much better though so welcome
Destiny to the iced coffee Hour podcast
this is truly an honor I was put on to
you by Lex Friedman oh cool you were on
his show for over four hours it was like
one of the longest Lex Friedman episodes
I think I've ever listened to in its
entirety it was incredible I absolutely
loved it and uh I feel like I hope this
isn't demeaning you are kind of similar
or comparable to the Ben Shapiro of the
left have you heard that before I prefer
to think that Ben Shapiro is kind of
like the destiny of the right Destiny of
the night both very intelligent fast
talking people and highly opinionated as
well sure but I respect it I absolutely
respect it and I'm excited to talk
hopefully on some policies some drama
you you recently signed a kick deal
right
um I did a three month one a while ago I
might be sending another one but um is
it absolutely it did end yeah it was
just for three months but I'm in the
talks of signing another one potentially
oh you are are you able to talk about
that
um I can talk about whatever I want to
talk about okay and you also have a
rumble deal as well yeah I do yes and
how's
why there's a lot of stuff
why are you signing with all these
companies instead of Twitter Youtube you
got more deals than we have well on
Twitch on primer band for being
transphobic I think that's why you got
permanent I I I guess so I'm actually I
don't actually tell you but what did you
say that was transferred initially I
thought that there's a part on the TOs
is you can't like discriminate people
from certain activities and there's a
lot of discussion uh the day before I
think about like stuff related to trans
athletes and everything so I thought
maybe I got banned for that then I've
talked to a couple people that are like
Friends of the company or work in the
company and apparently I got banned for
calling a bunch of people sub-human and
they sub-human yeah that's like my go-to
because it's like a it's not a slur
really who are you calling sub the group
of people I was fighting with but I
guess their interpretation was that I
was saying that all trans people were
sub-human so you're fighting with
someone who is trans yeah okay and
that's so you're telling that person not
all trans people that group of people
that person
what you were trying to explain is what
you think happened maybe I'm not sure I
mean it might have been an accurate
maybe they think that calling groups of
people like sub-human like a group of
people fighting with not good but I
think it was pretty obvious what I'm
talking I mean like I've got a big trans
Community I do a lot of trans issues on
my stream
um obviously I'm not transphobic but
when I was arguing with this computer
was like these extreme like activist
Types on YouTube are on Twitter are all
sub-human like it's not worth engaging
with them I'm not gonna bother so and I
think when they heard that their
interpretation was like well that could
be interpreted as him calling all trans
people some human so yeah what was the
ideology that these extreme trans people
were purporting that you disagreed with
or that you thought was subhuman there
is a um oh my God you're making me dig
back about a year ago
there I I got involved in a weird
personal fight with a Creator who
claimed that I brigaded their chat with
my chat to harass them but I hadn't even
I didn't even know this person existed
yet when that particular thing happened
um and then this was around a time when
we had been arguing about a bunch of
trans issues already and I am my
position on trans stuff is
um I believe that there is a fact of the
matter about whether or not a person is
trans and I think that having dysphoria
is an important part of getting trans
treatment and that kind of stands in
contrast to right now there's something
called the self ID movement which is you
trans if you say you're trans and I butt
heads a lot with those people and
because of my position which they
sometimes summarizes transmedicalism uh
they call me transphobic essentially and
how does twitch just go and misinterpret
what you have to say and then cut off
what would probably be your primary
source of income do you think this is a
problem within with twitch itself or
maybe do you think if you could go back
in time you would have rephrased what
you had said
um I'd probably rephrase it might just
be that sometimes twitch like slowly
evolves their standards over time for
what's acceptable what's not acceptable
and it doesn't necessarily go by the TOs
so for instance you're not supposed to
use the words like credit or autistic
that's bad for twitch but nobody
punishes for it so everybody uses the
terms of the platform you don't get in
trouble for it but I think one day you
might say it and they might decide to
start Banning for it so sometimes when I
ran to people some humans like a thing
they're just like oh this is I've never
got in trouble for in the past but maybe
now they've kind of updated internally
that people aren't going to say that
word anymore and that's what I caught a
band for maybe I'm not sure I don't have
like any official communication with
them so I'm like really guessing so they
didn't really tell you exactly what it
was you're kind of just assuming no it's
the email that I got was for hateful
conduct but that's it yeah that's a very
broad sweeping hateful I don't think
they're ever going to give you a
specific I think well they have no
incentive to it yeah any social media
platform they have the right to
terminate you at any point for really
any reason
you're on their platform at the end of
the day so if they make the decision
whether you agree or not I mean they're
not going to tell you because you said
this because then it gives you something
to just disagree with you know so but
then what do you think of the twitch
platform in general are you bullish on
it or do you think that these weird
policies make it seem like it's not
going to last very long especially with
all these other competitors with all of
this funding coming out and then buying
up streamers yeah very bearish um I
think twitch has a lot of problems
related to like uh company bloat like
that company grew to an insane size I
think they're having a lot of trouble
figuring out internally what they want
the culture of the company to be and
there's a lot of different stuff that a
lot of employees are working on that
aren't really providing any value to
users or to viewers at the end of the
day
um so yeah I'm not not too big on it but
I mean who knows it seems like a lot of
people are leaving right now I'm seeing
a lot of kick deals a lot of kick a lot
of Rumble yeah what do you think it is
about those platforms that
differentiates from twitch at this point
is it purely because they're throwing
money at creators okay
they've got the problem
um the issue with trying to build
competing platforms is a few issues uh
in my opinion I think a lot of the
talent acquisition is not being done in
the best way because the goal is to
acquire talent but you want their users
to stay on the site it's not enough to
just like buy a streamer and then have
them stream there and then hope that the
users like stick around like you have to
kind of build that organic viewer base
so that people are drawn to the site
naturally that's a really really
difficult thing to do I heard that a lot
of the kick revenue is coming from stake
and that when I went on Kick I saw that
gambling was one of the top things that
they were I don't want to say directing
people to but when you go to the website
on the top of the screen you see like
gambling and you see more people are
watching that than just about anything
else yeah which is probably why they're
trying to acquire more talents to get
other types of streamers on the site and
of course because I can imagine they pay
somebody let's just say 10 million
dollars to stream on there for a year
how much more Revenue are they going to
get on the back end from steak from
people who go watch gambling streams
think oh wow you know maybe I'm
interested in this too do it lose and
then that goes back and pays for the
create later I think ultimately the goal
is to make the site profitable I don't
know if it's only supposed to work as a
funnel to stake and then for steak to
give them Kickbacks to run the site I
think that's the goal but you should
bring that Eddie guy in an interview him
yeah what do you think about the ethics
of going on the site kick knowing that
potentially some of the money could be
used or it's funded by essentially
gambling money yeah I saw pokeman's
response to that which was really
interesting but the ethical and the
moral dilemma of are you I saw his
response yeah two Pokey Mains things not
interesting or I watched that none of
these tumors care about gambling they
just it's like platform Wars and
gambling is like the vector they use to
like attack like other platforms like
why do they attack it is it like a moral
grandstanding thing or do you think that
they could be insecure about their
viewership relatives that or do you
think it's a true passion thing like
they actually care about the people that
could absolutely not sure about your
thing I think that um there's a lot of
weird kind of like games clicky games
going on
um so like you've got like factions of
streamers you've got like train wrecks
and xqc and on that they're on one team
and then on another team you've got like
Hassan kind of like more mainstream
twitch people like fight with each other
like they're on opposing teams so
sometimes they so with the xqc and train
moving to one platform these guys might
feel incentivized to kind of attack this
because one these guys are on a
different team and these guys like fight
a ton with each other and then two
they're on Twitch and obviously they
feel some loyalty to their platform so
they want to attack like a competing
platform as well
what are your thoughts on the gambling
aspect of is that
I don't want to say ethically or morally
right but let's just say you have a
younger demographic of audience 10 to 18
years old do you think subjecting them
to gambling is a good thing to do or do
you think it's not worth it's a great
thing to do great yeah what was the
phrasing of that would you rather go
broke would you rather go would you
rather go broke at 13 or would you
rather go broke at 30. okay 13 year old
can't take loans they can't lose a house
they can't destroy their life 30 year
old can so it's good to learn that
lesson of going broke at 13. um well I'm
just saying because I think National
control is is something that has to be
fixed you know factored in that that you
know it's it's out there and it's up to
you to decide if that's right for you or
not I mean yeah for me personally I
don't like gambling much like I don't
think I would ever promote it unless I
got an obscene amount of money to do it
um just because it's not like in my
opinion from everything I've seen I'm
pretty sure gambling addictions are like
the worst addiction of like any
Addiction ever
um because like it doesn't threaten your
health so you could do it for an infant
amount of time there's tons of other
ways to get money the tricks and things
that are employed by casinos to make you
keep pulling the lever like mess with
your mind a lot so personally I don't
like gambling in terms of like would I
support a platform that has like
kickbacks from gambling that the when
you start to get into like ethical
consumption questions it gets very very
difficult once you get like one or two
levels removed to figure out like where
the responsibility lies because then you
get into like do I want to be on Twitch
because Amazon had that one thing going
with the workers in the warehouse no
tornado or the whatever or do I want to
be on
um Rumble because they have like far
right people on there that might you
know advocate for violence against
Jewish people like do I want to be on
this or not to say that like these
platforms are bad or even that this I
don't know what that happens but like
I'm just saying that when you start to
get into like layers of responsibility
removed in today's society everything is
so interconnected it's really hard I
feel like you could attack anybody for
any
thing ever so if you really really don't
like gambling and that's like a huge
moral sticking point for you which it
isn't for any of these streamers or
pretend it is but if that is a huge
sticking point for you then I'd say
maybe stay away from kick like you
probably wouldn't want to support the
platform maybe
um but yeah but before we go into that I
do have an exciting message to share
about our sponsor streamyard as I'm sure
you guys can see we have a pretty decent
setup unfortunately things like this are
incredibly expensive but it does need to
be if you guys check out our sponsor
stream yard stream yard is a live
streaming software that lets you create
high quality content with just the click
of a button all you need is a camera and
an internet connection and you can begin
streaming in minutes right from your
computer plus one of my favorite aspects
of this is that you're able to stream
multiple social media platforms at the
same time like Facebook YouTube LinkedIn
and more streamer also offers various
analytics tools to help you measure the
success of every single live stream you
do across every single platform so
you'll know which platform is driving
the most amount of traffic we absolutely
love streamyard over here they also
offer a free package so you can get
started without any risk it would mean
so much we genuinely love them and it
would mean a lot if you guys just check
them out with the link Down Below in the
description thank you so much oh don't
forget to manage I know you mentioned it
it's free it could be free they can try
it out for free for no money
checked it out in the district thank you
so much stream yard and back to the
podcast how would you describe your own
political philosophy um my own political
philosophy so I kind of have like these
very fundamental moral positions and
then from there I try to just build out
like what are the policy positions I
think that would make the world the best
for the most amount of people so right
now I tend to be like I'm very liberal
with a capital l so no socialism fascism
whatever I'm very liberal with capital I
very much appreciate like rights to
private property free speech and all of
that very much a capitalist I think that
that form of economic organization does
a really good job at allocating money to
different sectors very efficiently very
big on like social democracy I think
that the government should be involved
in kind of like funneling and channeling
a lot of the desires of society so
providing incentives for green energy so
that Capital markets can invest
appropriately
um yeah I'm pretty open socially like
I'm cool with LGBT people and all that
um very big on free speech like I think
that platforms are probably a little bit
too heavy-handed right now and banning
and censoring people for ideas I don't
want to discussed uh yeah yeah what are
these fundamental moral positions that
that you have like some of the main
biggest ones or most most important ones
that you hold closest to you that you
develop these political ideologies from
at the very very very very very very
fundamental level like I perceive myself
as a person that has some set of
preferences or desires um I perceive
that everybody else is about like 99
matched on those we all basically want
the same thing and then from there I try
to like build out like what are the
things and agreements that I can make
with other people to make sure that all
of us are kind of like working together
in a way that keeps everybody as happy
and healthy and functional as possible
so everything kind of builds up from
there kind of utilitarian
um I mean you could argue that sure
where do you think you got those beliefs
from I think when I was like 16 17 I
used to be really Catholic growing up
um and I kind of lost my religion
through high school just through
whatever normal growing process asking
questions not getting satisfactory
answers and in the process of kind of
losing that religious foundation for
life I kind of had to think of what
other Foundation I could find I read a
lot of Ein Rand and I realized after
like a year of that
um that I I really liked it and then I
at the end I was like well maybe I just
like this because I read the first
author after becoming an atheist and
this is just who I happen to like so
then I was like okay I'm gonna put that
aside and I'm really going to think for
myself like what do I think is important
in life what do I think is important for
other people and I try to figure out
kind of like these fundamental
principles and then any political
position rather than inheriting it from
like some political group or my family
or my country whatever I try to think
the best of like what do I think is like
a good Universal rule for society to
make people happy and healthy have you
always been a really deep thinker like
that otherwise has a deep thinker um but
I mean yeah I mean I'm a kind of a geek
a nerd I guess yeah but you seem kind of
like like a skeptic to certain things
like if you hear some sort of
information like the Iran thing like you
kind of supported it but then you beg
the question to yourself like well do I
really support this like you said
because it's the first book that you
read after becoming atheist or whatever
um what in you do you think causes you
to be so critical or open-minded I would
say to those things questioning your own
ideology questioning the other things
that people tell you is it something
that maybe a value your parents
instilled in you and your child or is it
just maybe the way you biological are
I'm gonna be honest I get really lucky I
took an AP Psychology class in high
school and that class like half the
class is just learning about how much
your brain lies to you about things like
the different biases you have the
different ways you search for
information the different ways you
remember selectively certain things and
that class combined with me becoming an
atheist and then engaging with other
people that were still very religious so
I saw that like I can't really trust my
own brain 100 and I see other people can
have very strong convictions about
things that I think they're totally dumb
on they're completely wrong on so in my
mind I kind of I try to have this like
underlying sense of not paranoia or
self-doubt but like for every um
I try to have like good mechanisms in
place to make sure that I'm not like
getting lost down some dumb I guess
uh so like here's like a couple of like
things that I try to keep in mind when
I'm arguing for a certain debate or
arguing a certain position I always know
the arguments on the other side and
their best most powerful Steel Man form
so oftentimes when I'm debating people I
usually know usually it's their side of
the argument better than them uh because
I spent so much time going back and
forth on it because I think if you don't
understand the opposing argument then
your argument could have a lot of flaws
or you could be you could be missing
something that you're not aware of
that's one thing a second thing is even
if I've got a lot of conviction about a
certain thing I'll always ask myself
like if I feel like I've got a lot of
conviction of finding a lot of people
I'll sometimes I'll tell me like what
would it take to change my mind on a
certain position if I don't have an
answer to that immediately then I'll
realize like I'm probably my conviction
here is too strong if I can't even think
of something that would change my mind
um yeah but there's like yeah there's
like a lot of things like that I just
kind of try to audit my brain a lot
especially not being like an online
content creator it's the easiest way to
get lost in like an echo chamber of
where you discredit every
outside voice and you just like circle
jerk with your own people and you never
consider anything different how often do
you change your beliefs
um I mean hopefully not too often
otherwise I wouldn't have any um I mean
like it really depends on the thing like
over time like I've evolved and changing
some beliefs sometimes I'll get posed a
really good question or argument and
it'll cause a pretty dramatic shift on
something but I mean my beliefs are like
Fair my fundamental beliefs are have
been relatively stable probably for
about 15 years but how those play out on
the abstract
um have changed pretty significantly for
a few things uh so like for instance
like one probably the biggest thing out
of two huge things I've changed on is
one I used to be like my single issue
for voting was citizens united I thought
that lobbying and corporate lobbying and
like Finance of Elections was like the
most important issue in the United
States I had a lot of arguments with a
conservative friend over citizens united
and post that case oh and then I
actually read what the the court
case was about which apparently nobody
does after reading about the court case
and then after thinking about it I
realized this is a really really
difficult question and I actually don't
think lobbying has anywhere near the
impact on policies in the US that most
people think it does so like that's
something that dramatically changed my
mind on so I assumed that lobbying does
have a big impact what have you found in
your end I just don't think it does
almost I think that if you wanna well
there's a lot of studies where people
try to like what they'll do is they'll
measure like what are the desires
they're rich people middle class people
poor people and then they'll try to
figure out like who gets their way most
of the time
um when there's like political
disagreements
um I I think that when I think that when
you're looking at um
when you're looking at like how
effective is lobbying or does lobbying
have a big impact on policy the question
that got posed to me that was really
interesting was can you think of any
major policy position that the majority
of the American people agree on that for
some reason can't get past because that
would be good evidence of like lobbying
attacking the will of the American
people or something and I kind of think
of a single example of that there are a
couple issues where it seems like that's
the case but when you dig into the
polling data it's a lot more complicated
than you think like the answer I always
give is like um
if you pull people I'm like do you think
the government should provide Health
Care to all of its citizens the answer
that is 75 people so it's like
overwhelmingly like well we should have
single-payer healthcare right but then
when you ask the question should the
American government uh Outlaw private
insurance and be the Sole Provider of
insurance support drops to that for like
25 it's like a 50 point difference and
it's like oh okay so sometimes people
say like oh all the American people want
this thing but when you actually like
get into more specific questions there's
actually a lot of disagreement about
what the American people like I think
that if lobbying is effective anywhere
lobbying is the most effective on kind
of like more Fringe issues that don't
don't have a lot of attention that's
what you can make the most effort so
like if tractors want to Lobby to like
make themselves narrower so that
corporations can make more money selling
parts or something you might be able to
Lobby effectively there because most
Americans don't care about it so like
influencing politicians and donating in
certain ways might be able to get you
some yeah the latest one that I saw was
about car dealerships that went together
and lobbied for Less oversight of the
loans that they issue that allows them
to issue more than the car's MSRP to
Consumers that hire interest rates so
you know like when you go and get a
credit card or a mortgage a lot of
oversight on that but you go get an auto
loan very little and that was something
they lobbied for sure but then you have
to ask yourself when they Lobby for it
is that something that most Americans
will be okay with or not okay with
because my guess is Americans going no
oh you guys do Finance here yeah am I
allowed to say Americans are financially
you know that so like my guess is most
Americans would actually probably be in
favor of that right so yeah that's true
that's interesting what are some of the
cognitive biases that you that you've
learned about in that AP class I'm
really curious I've always been
fascinated by that oh man there's so
many of them
um what stands out to you the most one
is
um there's something called
dunning-kruger
uh where basically the idea is that
people at really low levels of aptitude
dramatically overestimate their
competence and people at higher levels
of aptitude probably underestimate their
confidence
my favorite way to see this play out in
real life is if you ask somebody I don't
know this case but for my life you ask
somebody like hey somebody brings up
like Spanish do you speak Spanish and
somebody's like yeah actually I speak
like a I speak a pretty decent amount 99
of the time somebody gives an answer
like that is they took like up to
Spanish three in high school and they're
like donde El bibliotech or whatever
yeah but I know a lot of people like um
my mom is a good example if I asked my
mom like how like Mom how good is your
Spanish she'll be like ah it's like it's
okay my mom is a fluent Spanish speaker
she just doesn't know some technical
terms or whatever she'll say oh it's
okay that like on foreign language when
you ask people I notice that a lot that
if I ask somebody do you speak a
language if they're really if they're
conversationally fluent they'll be like
uh you know I'm okay because they
realize like how much they don't know
that shows up in everything usually
people have
um there's like a curve for measuring
this a theoretical curve or whatever and
there's like the the little bump in the
beginning is called Mount
that's where you learn a little bit
about a topic and because you've learned
a little you dramatically overestimate
how much you actually know and then as
you learn more and more you're like oh
okay maybe it's a lot more complicated
than I initially thought
um some people call that dun and Kruger
that's one example
um I think it's gonna be something
called a fundamental attribution bias
which is where when you see if there's a
group of people that you like and they
do something
um that's maybe not good you've got a
lot of good reasons why they did it if
you see a group of people do something
that's not good they don't get any of
that consideration so classic examples
like I'm speeding to work I gotta cut
somebody or whatever I have to get to
work I'm driving safe I'm doing anything
I can right but if you're driving you're
kind of chilling if somebody cuts you
off it's like what a
he's how dangerous or blah blah blah oh
a really good example of this um I think
oh God I should have the study memorized
but I think there was a study where
Republicans were asked to judge whether
or not welfare was like okay or not and
I think if you put like a white person
on the cover versus a black person if
they saw the white person they were more
likely to say like oh this guy's
probably down in his luck like he needs
a little bit of help blah blah blah
um yeah I think it's called fundamental
misattribution bias
um there's a whole bunch of cognitive
cognitive biases in terms of like
searching for information there's the
classic confirmation bias so I go to
search for information 10 things pop up
I only see the things that agree with me
and I don't look at anything else
[Music]
um
yeah out of the other so there's so many
different things if you're like research
yeah yeah I always find it interesting
that two people could have the exact
same experience but interpret it
entirely differently the same experience
same time they're right next to each
other two totally opposite opinions on
that yeah
that's frustrating but yeah it happens
yeah so let's talk about your philosophy
development over time and how it's
changed because I know that you've said
on podcasts before that you had a moment
where you were self-proclaimed red pill
red pill person not red pill maybe
libertarian libertarian was it yeah okay
when I first started streaming a long
long time ago um I grew so first of all
I grew up like ride or die Republican uh
my parents are still writered eye
Republicans
um all through high school I was a ride
or die Republican and then when I got to
working I was still kind of like pretty
conservative and then right before I got
into streaming I was probably my most
conservative and then I started
streaming and as I went from being broke
to making a lot of money I started to
realize like how totally an unfair life
was prior to making a lot of money so
over time over the past like 12 or 13
years My Views have slowly changed to
being more left-leaning basically so it
caused you making more money to realize
how bad it was when you didn't usually
the opposite right usually from what
I've seen it's like the more money you
make the more conservative you tend to
get I mean I can understand from a
policy position because people don't
want to like pay taxes maybe but yeah so
what made you
while you're making money to realize
that maybe these beliefs that I held are
not
um are not for me I don't agree with
them what specifically
um well like so this is something I
believe I firmly believe that
conservatives and liberals everybody in
the planet has like the same fundamental
values and like their first order kind
of thoughts are all identical so they
want people to be able to be successful
most people might be able to pursue some
sort of career and be successful
conservatives think that the answer to
that is
um leave people alone no government
intervention make sure the family is
healthy make sure people have enough
encouragement in their own lives to
pursue what they want and give people
the freedom to explore that and they
should be able to figure that on their
own because America anybody can do
anything liberals on the other hand tend
to say some people have some systemic
inequities is where they like these now
or inequalities that they can't overcome
so the government intercept and kind of
like give them a push to help them keep
up with other people essentially but
both of these like things I think stem
from the same place where conservatives
think this is the best way to be happy
and healthy liberals think this is the
best way to be happy and healthy
um
yeah the the that's the difference in
the two wait what was your initial
question my question was when you
started making money what changed your
belief in terms of what is that from one
to the other yeah
I think that as I so I probably started
with that conservative position but then
as I made more money I started to
realize that like with a little bit of
help like for certain people things can
go away differently and it would
probably benefit literally everybody in
society to have that little bit of extra
help there so for instance when I think
of like college or college achievement
in my mind
a kid who can go to college and do well
in college nothing financially should
ever stop that person that just
shouldn't be possible if you have the
ability to succeed we need to provide
those people all the tools to succeed
um on again a moral ethical level you
can argue an economics level because
they're going to be a higher taxpayer
contributor to the country financially
GDP and all that um that would just be
like a really good thing to do in my
conservative days I would probably think
like well if you're willing to put in
the work at the grades get the
scholarships you can do it but then as I
get older I see like well sometimes life
is sometimes stuff happens and
another thing I noticed was wealthy
families children have a lot of benefits
that not wealthy family or poor children
don't have that in a way work like
subsidies they just come from like Mom
and Dad instead of from the government
so like for instance something I noticed
growing up and when you're poor you have
a very very small tolerance for mistakes
like if you like if I like I lived in
Omaha Nebraska and I drove between Omaha
and Council Bluffs all the time and
anybody that's ever been on I-80 going
east to west or west east is potholes
all the time if I pop a tire or God
forbid break a wheel I'm like
financially for like three months it's
like over it's the worst thing in the
world so the tolerance for mistakes is
really low whereas today I could total
my car and go buy another one of the
dealership like tonight like it doesn't
matter so the so the amount of mistakes
that I can make are way different and
normally when you think of from I would
critique the conservative perspective
they would say well you should be able
to pick yourself up and do what you need
to do and and figure life out and if you
up that's your fault and it's like
I agree if you up it's your fault
but if you're poor you can up so
many fewer times than the people that
are wealthy you've got such a safety net
for Mom and Dad you know I've seen a lot
of poorer people have more motivation to
succeed because they didn't have those
things growing up and so they don't take
them for granted they don't just ignore
them for them it's like something to
Aspire to whereas because I went to both
a public and a private school and I've
seen a huge difference between them a
lot of the private school kids most of
them did well but quite a few of them
had everything handed to them and just
no motivation whatsoever whereas the
public school kids a lot of them ended
up in really interesting careers because
they really they would push themselves
isn't there a saying that like wealth
stops third generation third generation
most of the time some percentage uh it's
just gone yeah maybe I mean I would I
don't think that's true at all no way I
would fight to the death on that I went
to a private school and I went to a
public college and I was blowing the
away when I saw the difference in
educational outcomes between kids in
college and kids at the public when I
went to high school my my freshman book
was called college algebra and I thought
it was just called that to make us feel
smart or whatever and then when I
actually got to college and I realized
people didn't take algebra until they
were in college that like blew my mind
I'm sure there are
um oh here's another cognitive eyes
there's something called um survivorship
bias to where yeah if you see like a
thousand people in a shitty area the
only ones you're going to see after some
time are the people that made it out and
then it's tempting to say well I know a
lot of people from really bad
backgrounds that made it out like really
well so maybe everybody can do that and
it's like well those are probably the
exceptions to the rule rather than the
rule itself
um like a a really good example I can't
even think of this my own family I am
pretty Frugal with my money
um I drive a 40 000 car all of the
expenses that I have are generally
related to like just where I live like
I've got like a I think five thousand
dollar a month apartment and then other
than that I'd like and then travel for
work I don't like spend any money in
anything I have sweatpants I got my own
merch on I just I don't buy a lot of
I just don't so I I save all my
money the reason why I do that is
because when I grew up in my family
I'm sure you guys have heard of
Lifestyle creep that's like a way of
life for my whole family make some money
get some more debt make more money more
liabilities make more money like that's
like everybody in my family does that
and I think everybody picked up
financial habits for my parents I saw
what everybody else was doing I was like
I'm gonna do the exact opposite because
it sounds horrible so you could look at
me and go oh well look see because your
parents are so kind of like financially
um bad you became really financially
good so like maybe that was good for you
and I was like maybe but the rest of my
like six siblings are financially
horrible so I probably the exception
there rather than the rule how much of
that do you think just comes down to the
person though that that's just who they
are they tend to gravitate towards that
you naturally gravitate towards saving
that's just you in a nutshell versus
your environment I mean it's the reality
is is there's probably like a really
complicated Confluence of environmental
factors that kind of shape you as you
grow up along with some biological ones
and who's to say like what is the thing
or not that pushed you in One Direction
like maybe because I played a lot of
RPGs growing up and I saved all of my
potions for like the final boss maybe
that's why I don't spend my money like I
don't know maybe it's funny I was the
same way yeah I was the same way too
saved everything I had this one app on
my phone it's like this car racing game
I have millions of coins on there and
I've not sped Danny yeah so I mean who
knows why anybody turns out the way they
do it it's hard to say but like I could
think there's like 50 million potential
reasons why yeah I've noticed like one
of the most destructive things that you
can do to a kid is to give them
everything and then they feel totally
entitled and then they don't feel like
they have to work for certain things
don't you feel like that in a sense
could be replicated by a government that
potentially gives out too many handouts
towards people or do you think that it's
a completely different thing because you
were mentioning the education system
which I think is also different than
like
food stamps even I'm sure like that
would that would make sense as well
because obviously people need to eat and
everything but in other ways of of uh
like some sort of Social Security I mean
like there's with everything in life
there's a balance right
um You I think the goal for when you're
parent a kid is you you're not looking
to give them all the answers you're
looking to give them all the tools and
all the opportunities so a kid should
still be challenged in education and
challenged in life but you want to make
sure they have the appropriate tools to
deal with those challenges
um there's I mean like this probably
applies to every single thing in life
right like if you're like if you're a
normal human and you're not roiding up
um it's not like if you go to the gym
twice a day seven days a week that's
going to make you even stronger right
that's you're probably gonna get injured
you're not gonna make any gains you're
not gonna like you're that's gonna be
horrible right
um so you have to balance out like the
the working out with the recovery and I
think for Life a lot of that is like
kind of the same like some level of like
tension some level of adversity is a
really healthy for you because you
develop a tenacity to deal with other
problems later in life you don't want to
remove all adversity from children which
I think a lot of people today try to do
which is really bad so some adversity is
good but it can't be never-ending
adversity and and Trauma like um I think
they're called Aces and psychology
adverse childhood experiences
um based on like the amount of like
traumatic experience you've had a child
you can like make so many predictions on
bad physiological outcomes
cardiovascular disease lifespan all
sorts of things based on trauma and dirt
as a child so yeah there's just a
there's a there's a balance to be struck
you can't give somebody everything but
they should have the tools to deal with
like anything what's your experience
growing up
um like your adversities
um I think I just I lucked out on a lot
of things but it was not the best I
guess
um I don't know that's a very broad
question where you want to go growing up
what do you think your biggest obstacles
were growing up my mom did she did a
home daycare so my mom was very much
involved in raising like 12 other kids
because it was a 24 7 daycare that she
ran all the time
um my dad was working on other stuff
um he worked full-time and then did have
you ever heard of Amway
yes okay MLM yeah yeah yeah Amway New
Vision a lot of these like MLM things
um so I was kind of like left my own
devices up until
I think around like 12 or 13.
um
our life was like pretty decent I didn't
realize like how much debt my parents
had and everything but like we lived
like a really solid middle class life it
was pretty cool
um but I think when I turned I think
when I was 12 or 13 there was an issue
that came up where one of the kids in
the basement
um one of the boys I think he was like
seven years old like tried to pull the
pants down of like some five-year-old
girl some dumb kids do dumb my mom
talked to uh the boy's parents and when
the boy's parents heard this
um they pulled the kid out of daycare
and they reported my mom to CPS and so
Child Protective Services came out and
they did a big investigation and my
parents don't do any wrong or dumb stuff
like that so they were cleared
everything was fine but my mom was like
so stressed out by that event because
CPS is like when you're a parent is the
scariest thing in the world to have in
your house that she decided to
completely quit the daycare business
because she didn't want to risk anything
like that ever happening like losing her
children to some crazy parent or
whatever when we quit that we made no
money so all of our income went away I
we had this very awkward dance of
like being outside in the car a repo man
jumping in and like taking the keys
um utilities getting shut off all the
time so not knowing if there's like
water electricity
um eventually our first house got
um foreclosed defaulted on the mortgage
got foreclosed moved to another house
rented that for a while then got kicked
out of that my mom and sister moved to
Florida me and my dad moved another
house we got ran of that for a little
bit got kicked out of that and then I
eventually ended up living with my
grandma like a senior citizen apartment
complex for my last two years of high
school and then through high school I
worked my senior year I worked as a
McDonald's and then freshman to senior
year I worked as a it's called work
study where you could do like janitorial
work after school for two and a half
hours to help pay for your education
basically yeah so that yeah that's a
little bit of it I guess so senior
else do you think that also helped you
save in the sense that like you never
know what's gonna happen
if you don't spend too much you're gonna
have something to fall back on I didn't
understand I didn't know anything about
Finance at the time I know I did the way
that my parents described him was like
they were oh my God we were only like a
few payments away from owning the house
that's what they said and I was like wow
they got completely scammed by the bank
but now that I'm older I haven't asked
him my guess is they probably were
drawing down on the equity of the house
a lot through helocs or some other type
of like loan against the house or
something so
um yeah
but
um for eventually
um I mean I mean by the time I got older
and I saw like how they spent money and
everything yeah I definitely was like
when I make money like to me money is
just Freedom that's all it is it's the
freedom to either not work whether
travel or to be comfortable or whatever
and not have to worry about ever paying
a bill that's like the most stressful
thing in the world is when you're
balancing you know having to decide
which bill to pay the end of the month
is the worst feeling in the world yeah
when you were working as the Gen or a
janitorial thing uh that was all
throughout high school and you stopped
at senior year
um yeah it was it was a work study
program with my high school so we worked
at the high school first so then after
that College
um my senior of high school I was in
McDonald's for a little bit
um I was very very patient I don't know
why I'm very good at dealing with like
adverse people um I'm just just whatever
reason and I had a very challenged
customer come in and just give me a
whole bunch of stupid and talk
about it what happened I honestly don't
customers are just horrible
um I've always had a dream of like going
back and getting a job at McDonald's
like now and just waiting for the right
guy to my day up yeah and I'm just
gonna absolutely unload on him
and then like walk out in like a rented
Ferrari or some and just drive away
and just trash this guys into I
hate customers but anyway what is it
about customers though maybe is it just
Theory because they have no respect for
any person ever for their their but do
you think that's a confirmation bias
though no people are attacking well no
no to be fair most customers aren't like
this when you work on a service trip it
only takes one guy to really your
day up
um and the level of like entitlement
that people have and like the disgust
that they treat service workers with
like you're a slave
um God I remember
um my senior year in high school I'm
taking I'm taking so much math okay and
this guy at my cash register is telling
his kid if a cash register is not
working okay if it's not working you
can't process a sale okay it's a whole
point of sale system that tracks
inventory and everything it's not 19 20
four where the thing just does
the math for you so I tell the guy in
front of me it's a dad and his kid I'm
like hold on my register's down I can't
do it and the dad's like oh well the
change is like 72 cents and it's like
I'm dual enrolled taking like calc 3
difficult I don't need you to do
basic math for me and the dad goes to
his kid and he's like this is why you
need to study hard in school you don't
want to wind up not knowing anything
like this guy I'm like are you
serious that's just like one of like a
million examples okay and I'm like what
do you say what do you say to that do
you pretend like nothing I just
do my and whatever but anyway there
was a there was a customer who was like
screaming because there's like egg
McMuffin wasn't coming out soon enough
oh here's another thing customers do
customer will walk into a
restaurant okay and the customer like I
want an extra well done steak extra well
done and then they go on the center
table and then someone else come and be
like oh I want like a salad and they'll
sit down the salad will come out in like
a minute and the extra well done steak I
will come up and he'll be like where's
my steak that person was here after me
why did they got the flu before I was
like are you actually serious you know
like time works or
um but I think at McDonald's I think it
was something like that like a guy
ordered like a breakfast that was like
four or five items somebody came in
after them ordered something and they
just wanted like uh it was like a
mcmuffiner it was something really quick
or make Gretel or something and they got
it and then the guy came up he started
screaming like oh you guys always do
this you de-prioritize my order blah
blah
um I eventually got that guy's food I
just whatever I don't care and then the
next lady line was a supervisor at a
restaurant and a casino and she was like
oh you dealt with that really well you
should come work at the casino so I put
an application there I moved jobs to a
casino that paid way better my pay got
bumped from I think back then I was
thinking I want to say it was 5 15 an
hour was the minimum wage maybe it's 525
an hour
um so I went from that job to making 15
an hour at this casino which was Bank
I'm basically Rich at this point yeah um
how old were you at the time like uh it
must have been 18 or 19.
um I ended up going to college for
uh I want to go to college for music my
Casino job I was really really really
good at I'm very extroverted I'm very
social I knew all the workers there I
knew all the customers
um and I like to be like if I'm doing a
particular thing I like to be really
good at it so I could do everything
front of house really well I could do
everything back of house really well I
could cook I could do prep work I could
do everything I was a really good worker
but
um I don't know if you've figured this
out at all about me I have a problem
with authority in my mind if I'm really
good at my job and I'm doing everything
really well I should have a lot of
leeway to do things in an effective
Manner and I would I would bump heads
with my management on a lot of things on
a lot of stupid things like what one
issue that I remember came up was um I
remember with Excel right okay Excel is
a very powerful program it's not just
for writing notes in a
spreadsheet you do a lot with Excel one
thing that um one thing that we would do
is every single day whoever was
supervising for it was either swing or
graveyard I think depending what was
going on you would get from the uh
accounting department your cash register
variances every day
and what people would do is about an
hour shift a supervisor would go back
and they would take all the variances
they would put them into a spreadsheet
then they would take all of the variants
all of the cash register reports and
then they would take out a calculator
and they would add and subtract every
single thing every day to measure up
like where the variances are to see
people are missing money from their
registers this took about an hour every
day at one point I as I was getting
these things I noticed that when
accounting sentences it's always in the
exact same format and like when an
employee leaves or rejoins they even
leave like an empty space and I'm like
oh well if it always comes in the exact
same format you could probably just make
a spreadsheet and then just like do like
the little math operations program and
then so I figured out that like okay if
you make these like little formulas it
took me all of like 20 minutes it's not
very complicated copy paste this thing
and then you can calculate the variances
in about two seconds you just copy paste
them in and so I'm thinking like oh cool
I just saved every supervisor is like an
hour per shift and I talked to my
manager about this I got in trouble for
it and she was like we can't use Excel
because sometimes it makes mistakes and
then everything will get like messed up
like don't divert from the process I was
like what
um so there were a bunch of little
issues like that I remember on one issue
when I was working at graveyard shift
um first of all graveyard is where all
happiness and Norms go to die just
everything is horrible yes probably
everything in real life ever but um
my graveyard ships were very challenging
because one they gave me employees that
sometimes they could barely speak
English I had the Sudanese guy named Tut
who didn't know what a cheeseburger was
I worked at a diner okay so I'm like
teaching this guy to read while working
the register okay and I have very few
employees already and it's just it's
just a nightmare of a scenario
but I remember one day Pam comes in uh
morning shift that's my manager and I've
got there's a big like soda machine and
there's a bunch of fruit flies
underneath it and she's like Steven why
are there fruit flies underneath the
soda machine the grave shift you guys
should clean it up and I was like listen
I tell swing shift that they need to
leave this place a little bit cleaner
for me because you're giving me one
employee overnight there's I don't have
the time we don't have the manpower to
do this and she's like oh well why
didn't you talk to me about this and I
said I talked to all the swing ships
supervised about it and she's like if
you're not getting the answer that you
need to do your job effectively then you
need to email and CC the person above
the person that you're having an issue
with and I was like okay let's get
advice several months later as I'm we're
running these promotions at the casino
I'm getting more and more swamped for my
grave shift I'm running into issues
where
eventually in the morning a VP of like
food and beverage walks by the
restaurant there's a bunch of unclean
tables and then I get an email from Pam
saying hey just so you know VP food
beverages by wasn't happy with the state
of the restaurant and by this point I'm
leaving a lot out but like I'm getting
so swamped and at this job it's
like unreal they're having me cut like
my last cook at like three or four a.m
so I'm doing front of house and all the
cooking and everything on my own and
they're expecting this place to look
good by morning she was like impossible
so I may email her and then I CC the
head of food and beverage above her and
I'm like hey if you want these jobs done
I need more employees blah blah and I
didn't realize it at the time but I
basically marked myself for deletion at
that point yeah so past that there's a
there's a thing we call incorporate
called papering somebody out the door I
didn't like I was like aware of it at
the time it was even happening to me
because I think I'm such a good employee
so I'm getting fired then over time I
start getting written up for every
single little thing and I don't think
much about it because whatever like I
come into work like I'd only missed one
day of work in like three years but all
of a sudden I start getting written up
if I'm in like two minutes late like big
write-ups too and I'm like okay
um and then one day there's the
complicated scenario with a girl that
might get fired or not I end up getting
fired because I tell a girl that she's
gonna get fired if she comes in late and
I don't have the authority to fire
employees it was like a really
convoluted stupid thing
um yeah and that just yeah it hit me
like a ton of breaks they want you out I
still don't get that what was the reason
because I went above somebody else
because I think because I made my
manager look bad
because I emailed the guy above her and
then she didn't like that at all yeah
and I think that was I just I didn't
understand like corporate politics I was
an idiot I didn't play it correctly at
all that whole era of my life is really
bad because me and my girlfriend at the
time had we bought a house uh when I
like a year earlier and now I didn't
have money to pay for the house when you
were working at the casino yeah because
I was making a lot of money but after
getting fired from the casino I started
to fall behind on the mortgage instead
of fall behind on other bills
um it was kind of like stuck in like a
hopeless because I'm not going back to
school I'm stuck in a really shitty job
not making enough money for the
lifestyle that I had because my pay went
from uh at the casino I'm getting 20 to
15 hours for overtime and now for carpet
cleaning I'm working like 13 day
stretches because I get like every other
Sunday off and my take-home pays like
two thousand dollars a month so I'm
getting like completely
obliterated were you like in the red
then every single month
um it started to hit that point yeah and
what did your girlfriend think of the
time where you got fired from your job
and you're just kind of hanging out at
home playing Star Starcraft 2 while you
have bills and mortgages and stuff like
that um well it she was working at the
time so she didn't know as much but um
when she when she was it's not it's not
like I was not working and playing
Starcraft like I would only play in the
times between jobs because the issue is
for carpet cleaning like if I'm really
lucky you might get like an eight-hour
job and an eight-hour job you're getting
paid
um 16 an hour
um so however much that ends up being
um 80 and 40 whatever
um I'm working that and then I go home
147. yeah so yeah
um I work that job
um go home and then I've got like a
whole evening to play games right
um if if I if I'm lucky I've got like a
good eight hour job I make like a lot of
money I do that but if I'm but if I've
got like a lot of jobs scattered
throughout the day then I might be like
working like on the on call basically
for like 12 to 16 hours but I'm only
making like 30 or 40 dollars um
depending on the so like playing
Starcraft in between was it was the only
thing I could do or just sit around to
the I was doing nothing yeah and I'm
assuming this was the last job that you
had the carpet cleaning before you got
into streaming full-time yeah and that
was like did it take off immediately how
was the progression of your streaming
career I think it probably took about
six months before people were like oh
like you can solicit like PayPal
donations and stuff and I started to do
that after a few after like six or seven
months I think it was in December or
November of 20
um
2010 is where I got like my first payout
from I originally live stream then you
stream than a website called Justin TV
and I think they started a partner
program for some of the streamers and I
was one of the first people in it
um if not the first person I'm not sure
but they they I got a paycheck like 203
or something for like ad revenue for a
month yeah but when I got that 203
dollars I looked back and I just did a
quick calculation on like how many hours
do I stream and then how many hours do I
do carpet cleaning and it's like if I
stream the at the dollar per hour I made
streaming was about the same as my
dollar power carpet cleaning and I was
like carpet clean I was gonna stay
on and play video games and stream
because I make about the same money so
it and then from there everything
started to increase quite a bit yeah and
what what changes were you making to
grow on Justin TV at the time were there
certain like metas and different things
that you could do there was no the
streaming didn't really exist yet the
reason why I was able to start early on
was because there was a really high
technological hurdle because the
software was incredibly complicated and
streaming was very new so there weren't
even very many people doing it there
were no forums to help with any thing
but I was willing to dump a lot of time
into figuring out how to make all the
stuff work but like the hardware at the
time was not the greatest I think I was
using an ee 6750 like Duo core chip
um the yeah the software was horrible we
used flash media live encoder Camtasia
studio and a bunch of other things such
virtual audio cables get to work
um and then the data was insane I think
you were limited to like 300 to 500
kilobits per second for like a stream so
it was very very very very hard to get
everything working how many concurrent
viewers would you have at the time
um I probably started with like five six
seven and then I grew to like 10 20 30
40 50. and yeah and when you were at 30
40 50 is when it actually made sense to
be doing that full time uh yeah but I
was just because I was just making so
little money stream uh carpet cleaning
yeah and were you just playing video
games at the time or were you talking
about maybe different philosophies and
ideas that you have or was it purely
just like games it was just video games
like people watch me because I was
really good trash talk my background
before streaming was a lot of trash talk
and a lot of video game playing like the
whole reason I think why I even got
turned on a stream because I had a
friend recommend it to me he's like oh
some people do this and me and a couple
other friends would set up like Tekken
or Mario Kart outside the um one of the
classrooms at high school and we would
be like playing and screaming at each
other and talking or whatever and
he was like that was like a funny
experience like having other people
watch that would probably be funny too
so that's basically what got me into it
oh wow and then when did it start taking
off to the point where it actually
started changing your own personal
philosophies and ideas on policy to turn
you more liberal probably like three
four five years three four five years I
think it was once once my son started to
grow and I saw how affected his life was
by my finances that's when I think I
started to change my view on things a
lot so like the first year I did
streaming full time I think I managed to
make a hundred thousand dollars but I
didn't know anything about first year
you did full-time even 100 Grand yeah
but I didn't know anything about like
taxes or whatever so I wasn't paying any
taxes so my second year I had to deal
with that which was kind of brutal
um but I also the situation I had with
my girlfriend at the time our
relationship was very very very very
very bad
um so like she would live in my house
she got pregnant as we were breaking up
it was every well I say she got pregnant
I got to print we got pregnant
um and then uh it's not like she did on
her own yeah she just showed up one day
yeah so she was living at the house I
was like bouncing between all these
other apartments because we couldn't
live together without fighting
physically with each other so I'm like
bouncing around all these apartments
with these weird people I'm trying to
live with while I'm also trying to
stream at the same time
um so and then we moved to Poland for
three months to do because I was like
some gaming house or whatever
um but after I got home I'd say probably
like in 2014 my life started to get a
little bit more stable I started to make
more solid reliable money without having
to move around so much she got like a
place
um to stay and then when I started to
make financial decisions based on my kid
right so like which school district do I
wanted to be in you know what
opportunities I wanted to have then I
started to see things a lot differently
in terms of like how people's lives are
affected by the finance of their parents
that's probably what changed the most
and what did you and your girlfriend at
the time argue with or what what was the
reason why you guys were arguing was it
like fundamental differences or was just
like Petty random things where maybe
you're I don't know you you guys just
weren't compatible there's no chemistry
um but it depending on how deep you want
to go into relationship Dynamics I would
love to sure we love talking about
relationships yeah there's I think
there's like two primary methods of
settling disputes that people have one
is a group of people that are very
conflict avoidant one is a group of
people that are very like aggressive
pursuer to resolve conflict I'm very
much like an avoidant kind of person or
like if I'm if we're like in a triggered
like things are bad I just need like 12
hours to cool off and don't talk to me
and let me just like go somewhere and
for whatever reason every single person
I've dated has been very much like a
pursuer kind of person like we've got
conflict we need to resolve this right
no so usually with her the issue
would be I don't even we would fight
over it would just be really dumb
and then I'd want to be left alone and
then she'd want to resolve it now and
then that would escalate and escalate
and escalate until I would try to like
leave the house or we would end up like
fighting with each other over something
basically yeah how do you solve that
like how do you make that Dynamic work
um well now that I'm older the dynamic
probably would have involved better
communication from me and her about her
issues
um yeah setting more realistic
boundaries around resolving conflict if
you explain that concept to her that
also would have been good no that
doesn't help you don't think like you
say I'm a conflict the appointed person
like I just need 12 hours it doesn't
matter it's like it's like a conflict
person it's like a pursuer person
explaining to me well I need to resolve
this right now like so for instance my
my the current relationship with my wife
she's very much like um if she's got
conflict with me she needs to resolve it
right now and I'm very much like an
avoided person so one of us is like
always losing when it comes to resolving
conflict right like if we get into a
fight over something
more often than not it's because I've
done something stupid so we'll go and
she'll want to resolve the issue and can
you bring up an actual example or is
that too intrusive
um
it
no I don't want to bring up an example
it's usually it's like it'll usually I
know it's fine it should really make me
hiding or lying myself there's something
something really stupid I shouldn't be
doing but like um what will happen is or
not always also she up too okay no
but like we'll have we'll have like an
issue with something and um if we go to
resolve the kind of like but one of the
two things could happen either one it
has to resolved right now so she's gonna
like lean into me and she's like I need
to resell this video and then that'll
escalate to me being like okay Bubba and
so I get angry and I'm like you
you're stupid get out of here go back to
Sweden and then we'll fight like that
and it's just not good and eventually
maybe we'll resolving it's whatever that
so that would be like um if she pushes
too hard um if I get my way then what
will happen is we'll have a conflict and
then I'll get 12 hours to cool off and
at the end of the 12 hours I'll be like
oh yeah it's probably dumb it's fine but
at the end of the two of us for her
she's thinking like the whole time like
he's gonna break up with me like it's
over like he hates me like it's over
blah blah blah so there's like it's very
hard to strike a balance there because
it's either I get super triggered when
we fight or she's like left like feeling
like super panicky and triggered for
like 12 hours while I'm like chilling
out so it's really really hard for a
different people like obviously all you
can do is communicate we've got like
little strategies that we try to employ
like even if you hate somebody at the
moment like tell them you love them so
we're like still chilling things like
things like that to let us know where
we're okay but uh yeah it's it's a lot
of work to resolve that but I only get
like 20 I don't know if I would have
been able to or if my partner at the
time would have been able to because
we're young and stupid so and would you
consider yourself a pretty emotional
person
um like compared to other people
probably not as much but I mean like
yeah we're all emotional yeah
because it seems like if you're getting
into argument with someone like it seems
to me like you have a very rational
logical brain uh that you would be able
to see that hey maybe if I say FU you
know this type of stuff it's not going
to lead towards the direction I want
this conversation going we're like the
problem is is that like ration and logic
are like tools that can be emotionally
aimed at like anything that you want so
like if I'm fighting with somebody like
I can be like very logical and rational
but it might be like in a really
emotionally destructive way because I'm
like emotionally disregulated right like
I like if I get into a fight with a
partner like I might list like well
here's like seven good reasons why this
relationship should end you should get
the out of my face right now and
everyone will be like logically
consistent or like logical but like on
an emotional level like I'm being a
and what I should be
saying is like let's like think of like
a couple ways we can like fix this
problem so a lot of people have this
like dichotomy of like you can either be
logical or you can be emotional but like
I view things as kind of like a building
block like foundationally you've got
like a very foundational like emotional
Vibe feeling whatever's going on down
here and then your logic and reason
comes unfortunate really after that if
you're emotionally disre this took me a
long time this took me like 30 years of
my life to figure out because like I
consider myself like a logic Lord so it
took me a long time to figure this out
but you are incredibly a slave to your
emotional state and if you don't realize
that then you're yourself up in
so many different ways
um but yeah I read somewhere that when
you get in an argument parts of your
brain actually shut down that make it
almost impossible for you to hear the
other side or Reason logically it might
be yeah I mean depending on its time
afterwards for your brain to like start
functioning properly again after
something like that yeah probably yeah
depending I mean I know this like from
arguing with people depending on how you
attack an argument you can turn a
person's ability to hear you completely
off right away or you can do it in a way
so you can get them to be really
receptive to what you have to say just
depends on how you approach it yeah
but that's it's a very challenging
you've learned what the strategies are
and how to implement them or no yeah for
sure it just depends on the person
um and it depends on yeah there's a lot
of different things are there any
strategies that you could share it's
usually pretty specific to like a
particular debate but like attacking
like there there are just there's so
many things
um
yeah there are so many different things
to choose so like let's say that we're
arguing about like um let's say they
were arguing about like uh housing right
and we want to argue about rent control
versus like public housing versus like
zoning new housing or whatever
if I'm really trying to pull somebody
over to my side there's a lot of things
that I need to keep in mind one
reminding the other person we have like
a common goal like hey we want to like
have as many people's houses possible
Right like let's not lose sight of that
whoever's right or wrong in the
conversation we have a shared goal at
least
um that would be one thing a second
thing is like um don't ever attack the
person attack the problem that's like
relationship advice too right so now
we're like you're you're so
stupid why do you think this blah blah
blah but more like
um showing empathy like I understand why
you might think this might be a good
idea but you know have you considered
this
um having Grace when you're correct
about things is very important never
like look at this study it shows how
completely wrong you are like
what are you thinking but more like
Instagram yeah you bring one thing up to
Graham's like well I actually found 12
sources yeah I immediately phrasing go
to phrasing things like fine sources
yeah phrasing things that gives the
other person like agency or empowers
them is really good like I understand
why you think that
um but you should check out like this
study maybe it'll change your mind or
something like this is something that I
just found recently right you're kind of
like humbling yourself and giving them
the opportunity to be like oh okay yeah
maybe I would right so it almost feels
like it's coming from them instead of
like coming from you
um
uh yeah there's like it it super
depends on the topic but there's so many
different like little strategies like
this that you can employ
um providing people a soft Landing Pad
kind of goes with Grace if you change
your mind on something I'm not gonna
like hold it over you or judge you for
it like it'll be like oh cool like oh
like okay yeah you're right about this
particular thing it's like yeah like I
saw your point of view I understand but
you know maybe I think this is a little
bit better rather than like okay you're
right it's like yeah of course I'm right
you like you blah blah uh
yeah there's really with relationships
and debate and probably with like
business partners and employees and
employees and everything too there's
just like a lot of strategies like that
to be like you have to be very
empathetic very soft very graceful very
humble
um and you give the other person as much
kind of like space to like grow and
think and develop as possible without
being too aggressive because the problem
is there's a lot of like psychological
trips in the brain as soon as somebody
perceives that they're being attacked
they're no longer having a conversation
now they're defending themselves right
because if I come at you and I'm like um
you have this position on like abortion
or something and it's so wrong and so
stupid and you're mine you're
not thinking like okay he did is my
position let's hash it out in your mind
you're like he thinks I'm a
idiot well I can't lose the debate on
this topic because if I am I'm conceding
that I am a idiot so now you're
not fighting for the idea you're
fighting for your life at this point
okay you can't be stupid you're not dumb
you don't see yourself that way so the
debate becomes less about that
particular position and more about you
trying to salvage your integrity or
maintain yeah and trying to get them to
figure it out for themselves rather than
injecting your own ideology into that
space that you're hopefully creating by
showing Grace ideally yeah yeah so if
you be careful because in some of my
debates are going to do this really well
in other debates I'm not doing this well
at all it just depends on the
interlocutor but uh yeah but these are
things I try to keep in mind when having
these conversations how do you learn how
to do all this did you take a debate
class like how did you get so good
um I mean a lot of it you just learn a
lot of it is you know you don't just
learn it a lot of it is like very
deliberate like if I have a conversation
with somebody and I'll go back after and
I'm trying to think of like I'll try to
think of like how can I come off better
in this conversation
um like I was I was talking with a
friend earlier I just had a really
challenging abortion debate like two
days ago and in that debate both of my
opponents were
I don't want to say bad faith but
they're like cutting me off at every
single answer I'm giving and I realized
like 30 minutes into the debate they're
like okay we've moved past logic like I
need to figure out on a meta level like
how am I going to manage this
conversation because right now it's a
show
um and from that point there's just a
ton of different strategies that you can
employ I'll try one and then I'll think
back so like I think in that one I
started to get like a little bit snarky
I started to be like a little bit like
playful asshole-ish or whatever but I
might look back and I might say like
okay well maybe if I would have like
taken the high road out of a super calm
the whole time and chill maybe I would
have come off better but in other
debates there are times where I've like
been very chill very cordial even when
the other person's being aggressive and
I've gone back and I've reviewed that
I'm like you know when I look at how I
performed in that debate when I was like
very high Roady I very much was a
cordial person I actually look really
weak here because the other person's
laying into me and laying out their
whole philosophy I'm barely getting in
any words and I'm not like defending
myself at all so I just end up looking
weak in other debates there have been
times where I'm very aggressive and then
I come back and I'm like you know if I
would have just chilled here and given
this guy more time to make mistakes and
look stupid I would have come off way
better to the audience so there's a
there's a big balance again it's a very
complicated study basically yeah yeah
it's delivered that's what I'm saying
it's deliberate it doesn't just happen
naturally it's like reviewing debates
reviewing conversations and then varying
like your approach to see like how do I
think an audience excuse me how do I
perceive me and then reading a lot of
feedback YouTube comments subreddit
posts 4chan posts other YouTube posts
streamer chats like things on Twitter to
see like how people feel about a
particular conversation why is it so
important to you
um my place this much time on debates
and getting your thoughts across huh
cause I'm really good at it so if
anybody's gonna do it it's got to be me
um no I mean I super enjoyed it's really
fun for me it's like a very it's like
when you when you go to debate somebody
there's like seven different huge skills
like conversational like intellectual
like research and prep
um your demeanor there's like so many
different things that go into it it's
such a complicated back and forth I do
think I'm pretty good at it I think
people recognize that I do feel strongly
about the ideas that I have and I'd like
to convince more people to think of them
um I make a lot of money doing it so
it's like a fun career path and it
enables and unlocks me to do so many
like really fun things in my life like
if I wasn't doing streaming I would
still be on Reddit or Twitter like
arguing with people and like
talking like that's just the kind of
person it was like really fun for me
yeah and just to finish up this
chronological story of your entire life
that brought you up to this table today
you were streaming you became very
successful Justin TV turned into Twitch
TV you were doing twitch for a while can
you talk about your income over time my
income over time was
um I think I made like a decent amount
of money I think in my like first
my first like five to ten years I was
probably making like low six figures 100
to 200k a year maybe so very stable yeah
pretty yeah very stable not growing if
you were continually going on Twitch was
was your community just like subbing in
and out there are some things that like
came out and then dropped off like in
the very very beginning days of Justin
TV like the ad Revenue was insane I
think off of like three or four thousand
viewers I could like make eight thousand
dollars a month in ad Revenue which at
the time was like really big and really
good and then like that completely like
fell off the map then subscribers were
introduced to Twitch eventually
um I made my own website to manage my
own subscribers so I started to make
more money there
um yeah it probably it probably grew a
bit over time I don't know 100 it
probably would it probably went for like
100k to like three or 400k it probably
was growing steadily but I didn't have
like any explosive growth my growth has
always been like pretty stable the whole
time and then my biggest most recent
explosion explosive growth income has
come from my YouTube channel which was
my greatest mistake of not starting that
like I had a YouTube channel like 10 or
11 years ago that I think got to like 70
or 80 000 Subs which back then was like
pretty good and I abandoned that for
like eight or nine years and then just
like I want to say like four years ago
maybe I started taking my YouTube more
seriously again I should have been doing
that the whole time but that's been like
my most recent like big income bump are
you comfortable to talk about numbers
that you're currently doing right now or
is that off the table yeah I guess if
you want to sure sure yeah so YouTube
Curious yeah so what percentages or
numbers is is like YouTube versus twitch
or sorry not twitch versus twitch yeah
versus like the kick deal versus Rumble
and all that stuff so my website is
where I have my own subs and people can
donate through there I think on that I
make about 250 000 a year I think is
what I made last year they were on
Twitter is that like an email thing or
no it's just you go to destiny.g and
then you can subscribe there you can
donate there it just it runs as its own
completely side like chat and egosis or
whatever oh so you stream on there as
well no it's just an embed from like
YouTube or twitch oh okay well not
twitch but yeah
um YouTube ad revenue is really good I
probably like around like anywhere from
40 to 60 2000 a month off of that and
then I've got like two other channels
that make around like 20 to 30 000 a
month I pay like 45 of all that ad
Revenue goes to my
um my YouTube editor who's definitely
overpaid August uh no I'm just kidding
um 45 that's a lot yeah I do yeah all of
your channels uh yeah he gets a lot of
money no yeah when did you when did you
agree to that deal a long time ago
before it was making
um much I mean it's like 100k basically
the the it's
um yeah he does really well but um the
basically the way that I saw it when I
initially did it was no idea is Jack
when I initially did it my idea was
basically that
um I want him to be as invested in the
channel growth as I am and I don't want
to do anything I don't manage anything
on my YouTube he does every thumbnail
every video nothing I never look at it
ever I get to check every basically a
month from completely satisfactory 100
yeah
um if I went back in time I probably
would have started at a lower rate
probably but like I'm okay with him
making a lot of money he's made me a ton
of money he's made me like really
successful like I'm cool that he can
sharing that success that's really
awesome editors now
um he might be hiring out other people
it's his job is his money whatever he
can do with it so yeah interesting okay
and then you of course you have the the
rumble and the cake deal does your
editor get a cut of those deals as well
or just the videos you guys paid enough
okay don't give him any ideas listen cut
that part out
that's funny okay cool so um your
philosophy developed over time when you
had your kids uh and then obviously when
you started making more money you saw
how much of an impact that makes on a
child's life interesting so my guess is
then you think you should probably pay
more in tax or what do you believe in
this is my view on taxation yeah okay
it no I'm just kidding um I did
leave California for a reason no uh well
yeah but um there are certain social
programs that we should advocate for in
the United States and we should have
those social programs and then we should
tax people accordingly that's my view of
it so some people are like very moral
and like we should pay more taxes and we
should pay less taxes like I'm not here
to punish anybody with tax I don't care
about that I just whatever social
programs we have we should fund um I'm
okay paying taxes I'm okay with a
progressive tax system like I I
definitely pay all my taxes
um
but yeah I'm never one like when
somebody said should we pay more or less
I'm like we shouldn't have the social
programs we need and then we should fund
them so right now like the rate of
Taxation for wealthy people is probably
a little bit low but
um my biggest complaint living in
California was the state taxes here are
really really really really really high
I think the highest in every other place
except for like New York City yep and I
don't know where that money goes Nobody
Does it goes to a rail system that was
never built oh the billion dollar rail
to Nowhere whatever yep
um oh and the lamps did you guys see the
lamps what was that nobody else has seen
the Lambs I felt crazy it was either it
was like San Francisco or San Jose or LA
or somebody there's like ten thousand
dollar lamp installations on the street
and no one knows what they do YouTube
videos are like this two million dollar
public bathroom I've seen that one it's
like a tiny little like normal public
bathroom it's like yeah someone did an
investigation of how this thing cost two
million dollars when the market value of
that should have been about 80 000 and
they win and they investigated and they
interviewed people who were involved
that everyone was silent and it seems as
a lot of money went to permits
developers contracts random things and
overpaying so if someone gets a budget
of a million dollars they'll spend all
million dollars saying well this
concrete is 10 times more because you
know this is what the budget is so it
seems like a lot of money wasted on that
it's very strange because like America
is like the freest most capitalist
country and blah blah on Earth but we
have so much like bureaucratic red tape
on like construction everything it's
like insane spend all of your budget if
you want to get it back because it
really upset me was that downtown Los
Angeles they wanted to build a homeless
shelter there and I forget I don't know
this is
yeah sorry so they wanted to build a new
one downtown Los Angeles and so someone
investigated this that they had signed a
lease and they had been paying for like
six years now 50 000 a month for a
warehouse
they have not even started construction
on it yet they've not built it yet and
apparently it had Foundation issue and
they couldn't do anything with it yeah
the issue they kept paying it for years
and so what it came down to was that the
person who signed this did a deal with
their friend and they had a business
connection to spend all the money in a
lease so that their colleague could get
all the money for that without providing
anything in return nice it's still going
well so usually for a lot of stuff like
that what will happen is it's like you
rent something you discover there's a
problem then you have to contact an
inspector then you have to wait for the
inspector to come out then he gives the
okay then like the city comes out and
then they okay and then step one of
whatever thing happens and then another
inspector comes out and then it's like
it's just such a nightmare but yeah
that's my my big problem with LA is that
like
okay by the thing that really my
head up was anytime I travel to Europe
there are so many social services and
everything available that seem to run
pretty well like they're not perfect
they've got their problems but like
public transit in all of Europe is
awesome and then I come back to
America and I'm paying
like now I live in Florida my tech
situation is cool but when I live in
California I've got a huge cost of
living I've got huge taxes and a massive
state tax like I want to say my
effective tax rate
um like two like I want to say like two
or three years ago my effect taxi was
like 42 or something and I'm like I'm
like I've seen routinely more than 50
yeah I'm like paying like European
levels of taxes here like this is
wild like why why how am I
paying like I'm supposed to be making
fun of people in Europe for paying this
level of Taxation
um yeah so yeah that's that's my issue
I'll gladly pay a lot of taxes I just
want to like get something for it I
guess like if there's like a functional
public transit in La maybe I'd feel
differently or what's crazy with
California the short-term uh capital
gains tax rate is something about 53
really yeah short-term capital gains
because your tax is ordinary income yeah
and then you have to pay state tax on
top of that and if you make over a
million dollars a year there's another
3.8 net investment tax that gets paid on
top of that oh so when you say
short-term count against you're just
talking about the the net additives
so it's it's Hefty can we talk about
that Lex Friedman interview you did
which are how was that like did he just
reach out via DM or something like that
because I'm a huge Lex Friedman fan and
that like I said before we started
rolling your suit today I should have
worn my suit yeah that was the first
time I was actually exposed to you and
it was also I think it might have been
back to back or very close to when he
posted one of the Ben Shapiro which I
also really enjoyed I watched both yours
and Ben's and I thought they were both
really incredible great perspectives can
you talk about like did he just DM you
did he email you I had some crazy stuff
going on on my stream for a while and I
think he started to show up on my stream
chat after finding he's watching you
yeah after finding me through another
streamer yeah that was weird because
we'll be like talking on chat about like
is it moral to have like incestuous
relations with twin brothers and then
like Lex Friedman will like donate like
10 bucks like I don't know what I walked
into it I'm like just leave so you know
it was Lexa yeah yeah yeah so he watches
a lot of streams sometimes I guess like
he spends time doing things yeah
interesting so then he just he was a fan
of you he started he originally he was a
fan of another streamer there was like a
mutual friend of ours kind of and then
he found me through that streamer and
then he started watching me and then he
invited me out eventually yeah and how
was that was that just a real experience
yeah was cool he seems like a really
almost say naive is like maybe a
negative way but for the most part he's
like a really genuinely friendly fun guy
who just like wants the best for
everybody you know so like not even the
best way I guess yeah interesting so I
remember there was one thing that really
stuck out to me from this interview is
you quoted your mom and she said
something like Stevie don't be so open
your brain falls out and then Lex
immediately like slammed the band hammer
down he was like I can I could not
disagree with that anymore could you
explain what exactly that means and why
you believe it
so
um oh God there's like a Socrates quote
I'm living in quotes right now where
it's like it takes it takes the mind of
an intelligent man to entertain an idea
without accepting it or something so
something that I work really hard on in
life is I like to be able to look at a
lot of different perspectives without
losing myself and it seems like people
typically go one of two ways either
you're very open to everything but then
basically you repeat whatever the last
thing was told to you so like I would
have a critique with Joe Rogan that I
feel like he kind of does this where
anybody that comes on he's like okay I
see this is kind of cool and it doesn't
really challenge as much or you have
people that are dogmatic and can't hear
any other idea like everything else is
stupid wrong dumb and I'm not gonna like
even entertain the idea something I hope
I can do or that I like to be able to do
is I have an open enough mind that I'll
entertain other people's ideas I'll try
to understand other people's
perspectives but I very firmly have like
my own beliefs and thoughts that I
believe in and I'm not going to change
my mind just because like this thing
sounds interesting I guess so
um don't ever have your mind so open
that your brain falls out just means
don't let the last person that talk your
air off like convince you of like every
single new thing that they decide to say
basically what do you think about core
principles and then allowing your core
principles to be changed do you think
that that's a good idea or do you think
that those corporate core principles
that you identify with are some of the
most uh I would say distinctive features
of who you are yeah core principles are
distinctive and really important the
only thing that should change core
features is if if your life is
constantly on like a bad trajectory or
there's some incongruence with where you
want to be and where you are and that
seems to be getting messed up over and
over again then it might be time to go
back and reconsider some core principles
but um yeah that's going to be super
individualized to the person on the
event but yeah but I would say anytime
you're having a lot of issues over and
over and over and over and over again
and nothing seems to be working or
changing then it might be time to like
go back to the drawing board and
refigure like okay like what something
is wrong fundamentally like I need to
figure out like what's going on yeah
and uh can we talk about your
relationship sure are you cool with that
so Grandma I don't know if you know this
but he's in a open relationship right
with your wife so you guys are able to
see other people how did you come to
that conclusion
um
okay my last relationship I cheated you
cheat I think yeah
not really that surprising
um I'm sorry like why um because I'm a
horny and dumb and it's whatever
um
the what I realized after that
relationship was like I am just never
gonna date again because I'm too Kumar
brained and I can't the idea of like
being with one person for the rest of I
just can't I can't ever do it it's never
gonna work it's never gonna happen and
rather than subject somebody else to the
horrors of dating me and being shared
with me I'm just gonna do my own thing
on my own it
um so for a while I did that and
eventually Molina uh my wife she reached
out to me via Instagram and we kind of
started floating a little bit and I was
going through some weird stuff in
California and then I had like a job
opportunity pop up with like a sponsor
camera system and I was like oh she's in
New Zealand I've got a few friends in
New Zealand I'm gonna go to New Zealand
hang out with her for a bit talk to
other people and when I went down to New
Zealand she has a lifestyle where she's
like polyamorous and then she describes
this to me and I never even considered
it before and I'm like okay this sounds
kind of cool
um and then eventually we started
talking when we started dating and from
the outset basically we've had that
style of relationship because I guess
she was involved in it before and then
once I found out about it this is like a
dream for me because ideally it means
that I can like work on my stuff do my
and my partner doesn't seem is like
their sole source of like uh
entertainment or whatever they need
because they have the opportunity to go
do other things and then if I want to I
can go do other things this should be
okay
but why get married are you married to
her yeah why why get married in that
sort of because she's Swedish
yeah yeah because without without
getting married she can only see me like
three months out of the year so got it
okay how does I don't get how it works I
don't get how this how how fundamental
do you want the conversation how does it
could you explain that no I don't get
how either side could not get jealous
possessive
um wanting that person all to themselves
that seems so foreign to me that she
could be off doing something and I'm
here
my mind could just not process it as
would like I can't do anything you know
sure to me I just I couldn't
I think there's probably some I think
there's some like natural level of
jealousy that exists for literally every
single type of interaction
um like even in monogamous relationships
somebody might get jealous if their
significant others like has a close
friend of the opposite sex or like is
saying good things about somebody else
like that that you view yourself as a
competition to
um that if they do things with friends
you want to be inclining like there's a
lot of like places in life where
jealousy and stuff can pop up
um obviously your partner getting railed
is probably one of the more prone to
jealous environments that can happen I
guess the way that I view it is
there are certain things in life that I
really want to be able to do and being
able to like hook up with other people
and it's like really fun for me but I
also feel like very secure in who I am
and what I offer and what I can offer to
other people and I don't think that my
partner hooking up with another person
is gonna make them not like me because
I'm an awesome person uh so if they want
to go and explore stuff like that as
long as I have the opportunity to as
well and like we know we both love each
other for me it's not that big of a deal
does it ever concern you that you could
potentially not be that way for the rest
of your life and you've said this as the
foundation of your relationship with her
this is going to sound very brutal but
the um it's gonna be the most um Chicago
School of Economics answer I ever give
if at any point in time I'm not like a
good enough partner for my person the
last thing I would want is some
monogamous bound like keeping them like
locked to me like that's how I view it
basically so if my partner ends up
running into somebody and they like they
treat her better they make her happier
she has more fun with them and all that
and she's like listen like I think I'm
Gonna Leave This person I mean you
probably should very matter of fact
about it yeah I mean like I might be I
mean like at that point core principles
at that point I would have to evaluate
like okay here's my wife I love her a
lot she's met another person who
provides all these things that I don't
provide so then at that point I have to
make a decision do I want to change
myself enough to provide those things or
do I like what I provide and what I can
get and then I go find somebody that's
more like synergistic with that let me
ask you this would you prefer if she be
monogamous
like all things considered just the
Situation's exactly the same you can
still do whatever you want but she's
monogamous would you prefer that no why
um so okay I'm bringing with a lot of
norms here I'm sorry
um ever since I was in high school I
have a very aggressive personality
um I really like strong characters I
really like strong character in women
like my first wife like was very much
like we would argue and fight all the
time for fun but like we very much like
I need people to like call me on my
it's like be like stirred and
everything if I have like a partnership
with another person like a wife or
girlfriend or whatever like in my eyes
it has to be somewhat equal like if I
was out sleeping with people and my wife
for whatever reason didn't want to or
never did or she was monogamous like I
would view that as her not having any
self-respect because she I'm basically
getting a really big ask from her for
like some sexual loyalty and then she's
letting me go out and do whatever I want
and at that I'm like why would you ever
agree to that unless I've got like so
much leverage over you or you're like so
much beneath me that I have the ability
to do that like that's how I view it I
understand everybody view about it
that's how I feel if it wasn't sexual
loyalty but it was more so she just
didn't have any desire for anyone other
than you oh I mean if she didn't want to
then I wouldn't care but it doesn't make
a difference but if she didn't want to
I'd probably would give it the only
thing that logistically that probably
wouldn't work out though because if I'm
out like hooking up with other people
some other people and she's just like at
home it's like what the is
happening like my husband should hang
out with me and he's like out you know
hang out with random chicks like me
you know so how do you draw those
boundaries do you just say hey we have
open discourse over who you're with who
I'm with and of course we have this time
that we reserve for each other uh it's
very difficult and we're still kind of
working that out um for a variety of
reasons but the the idealized form of
our relationship is usually we both have
other people that we like to see and if
we're traveling assistant people uh
ideally not always but ideally sometimes
but the um basically if somebody's going
to go hook up with somebody or trouble
to see somebody then the other person is
doing it at the same time that's like
the ideal so that everybody kind of has
something to do
um at the same time and nobody so you're
like hey honey I'll be back in a few
hours you're going back in 20 minutes
well I think we usually it's the goal
would be to like plan things out like in
advance kind of so like if she's gonna
travel to like New York to go do a photo
shoot and she's got like a friend up
there whatever then I know that like a
month in advance maybe I'll plan to like
hook up with somebody in Miami while I'm
there someone like that right
that's I don't know okay so as a person
who has only been monogamous and who
plans to only be monogamous monogamous
for the rest of my life just based off
of who I know I am
when I look at a relationship like this
I cannot help but feel and I'm not being
judgmental towards you in any capacity
all the best comments start off with
that guy
no disrespect that there seems to be
less love in a relationship that is like
that can you dismantle that argument
with facts and logic uh not at all
there's a lot of these things are very
emotionally driven I understand the
argument that like if we're in love with
each other you should only have eyes for
me
um and we only you know make love with
each other because that's a special
thing in a relationship I understand
that argument uh if I were to try to
attack that as brutally as I could on
the other end um if I would have come at
it from like I'm Polly I don't
understand people what I would probably
say is that like for me
um if my wife and I lost our genitalia
we would still have the exact same
amount of love for each other I know to
find the love that I have for people or
especially my wife by the fact that we
have sex or some sexual exclusivity has
no bearing whatsoever on my feeling for
her like there are reasons why I love
her there are reasons why I like to
spend time with her and do things with
her and travel with her and all these
things and these things exist wholly
into currently from the sexual component
but sex is important in love yeah for
sure because but it's not like it's not
here's the thing I right now I can
any person that I can but the
special moments that I share with like
friends or my wife are moments I can
only share with her I have a lot of sex
a lot of people but I can't have the
same type of time that I spend with my
wife with any other person that's just
not possible so like that's the thing
for me that defines the relationship
there's a lot of people that I've had
sexual experiences with there's not a
lot of people that I've had like really
loving vulnerable caring kind nurturing
moments with yeah how do you feel like
your relationship affects your son
seeing this
um man I don't know anything for him
he's gonna be all sorts of up I
think it's all about
um the policy that I have with my kid is
a policy I've always had for myself I am
very very open and very honest about
basically everything
um like even when he's six of you ask me
a question for like how does a car work
like I'll try to describe everything I
can I never want to say like oh like
you'll know when you're older oh I just
want to blah blah I try to keep things
age appropriate but like because I've
been like so open for so long I think
that generally like because me and Mom
are split he's got his household with
his mom and he's got his whole family
his mom's side his grandma grandpa and
everything over there and then he's got
me and then hopefully like my wife so
like when I fly into town or when he
comes to Miami he visits me and then he
knows that like he knows we're married
he knows my girlfriend and we hang out
but because because we've been split the
entire time I don't think he had to
undergo that Schism of like why aren't
Mom and Dad together anymore and I don't
understand why there's all these other
people and blah blah blah that's just
kind of like what he's always known as
the norm and for all the faults that me
and Rachel his mom had in our
relationship she does an amazing job
being a mom and working with me in terms
of like working with my son like we
don't have like a formal custody
agreement we have a lot of conversations
about like like if he's having certain
problems that are related to like boy
things like she'll talk to me and she's
like hey can you have this conversation
with him about like viewing this on the
computer or talking to people to swear
blah blah so she does a really good job
at like keeping me in the loop and that
I do a good job of communicating with
her about that so yeah does she disagree
with your choices now in terms of having
an open marriage
um worrying about like hey I don't
believe in this from my son no but we've
never had that conversation I imagine
choose I don't think that we'll try to
force I guess I've never had that
conversation with her before I don't
think she she thinks I'm a little crazy
I think she's a little crazy but like we
live our lifestyles but like I don't
know if I I would never like impart on
my son like Hey listen you want to grow
up and be a high value man and juggle
five women but like I'm not gonna say
anything like that like I figure he'll
discover and explore that on his own but
he's also say 12. so yeah I feel like
that's about the age right if you're
polyamorous I I don't know when you're
figuring yourself out and you know
listen if you're a 12 year old guy and
you can manage multiple relationships
and what is that sixth seventh
grade go for it okay
um but no I imagine there's like other
stuff he's got going on developmentally
that he's probably not fixated on you
know joining the Mormon church and being
polygamous or something yet so sure but
yeah I mean I imagine when the
conversations come from the future we'll
just talk about it and what about when
you meet somebody else are you just up
front and say hey I have an open
marriage or if if they reach out to you
they already know the situation I try
um I try at this stage of my life to be
I try to be as upfront with everybody as
possible because when you start like um
lying about certain things or
obfuscating things or masking things
then can get very very complicated
very quickly so yeah like like Molina's
on like my Instagram we like talk
publicly about each other it's not like
no there's no secret there that we're
married or anything so I try to be like
pretty open about all that Graham and I
contend over who we have on the podcast
quite often I know that you've at some
point collaborated with Nick Fuentes
who's a very controversial person now I
want to know what your stance is on
bringing certain people onto your
platform and giving them exposure albeit
you're you know contending with them and
disagreeing with them and maybe raising
really good points that uh go against
what they're saying what do you think
about giving them I would say another
like a microphone it's a very very
challenging Balancing Act but I'll tend
to hear out most people with kind of
like that open mind philosophy like come
in talk to me and then I'm gonna try to
tell you why I think you're wrong about
being as empathetic or anything as
possible the something unique that I
provide that I think is really important
to some of these alternative communities
is I'm like the only person that is
Progressive that like isn't
unhinged and I think it's really good
sometimes to show people like hey you
can be Pro LGBT you can have like blue
hair be in like weird relationships
whatever but I can be like a funny cool
charismatic like we can have fun and
chill and I can be like understanding of
you and not be like super judgmental to
try to cancel and be horrible for a lot
of people I think that seeing somebody
like that on my side is really important
because representation for progressives
is absolutely dog right now
on the internet so to some extent when
I'm platforming other people that's a
thing that I'm keeping in mind there's a
lot of those communities that I've
interacted with who I'm like the first
positive representation of like a
left-leaning person they've ever seen
that's one thing
second thing is if I am platforming
something Buddy like that I'm trying to
make sure that everybody understands
where I'm at like I'm not just having
the person on to like laugh and giggle
and like play games like generally like
with Fuentes it was a lot of debating a
lot of arguing over different points
um so hopefully one I can demonstrate to
his audience that there are at least
some arguments on the other side
um and then two my audience can see the
arguments I'm having and then they've
got like more tools to like deal with
that type of stuff in the future one
thing I don't agree with is I don't like
burying your head in the sand and
pretending that some people aren't
saying certain things you should be able
to deal with a lot of those arguments
without being like Oh my God my whole
audience suddenly turned into Nazis
because I think we've gone down that
road so far that and I think platforms
are finally starting to reverse course
we got to this ridiculous world where
like half the country is believing in
things that you can't talk about on any
social media platform can't talk about
vaccine skepticism can't talk about
election uh being stolen uh can't talk
about like covid-19 uh theories or
whatever I personally I think these
things are harmful ideas I think they're
bad but if how half the country believes
in them how are we not having
conversations about them how is nobody
allowed to talk about problems like the
algorithm where once you get on one of
those topics the algorithm is so good
that it just recommends more and more
and more and they pile on top of each
other and then you get more and more and
more extreme because those are what's
getting clicks that's what's keeping
people on the platforms yeah but the
goal is to chop it off right there yeah
but I mean the chopping the sharpening
of the sword should be on the side of
the people arguing against it right like
if people are getting lost on like
certain algorithms it happens on the
left and the right where people get lost
on certain algorithms
um people on the left need to do a
better job of providing better arguments
in like a more entertaining way because
I feel like people on the left are so
like dogmatic and then they're so like
condescending in their approach where
it's like you either believe me or
you're an immoral bigot and that's all
I'm going to say to you and then on the
right like all of their figures are like
highly entertaining right the tastes are
very entertaining Alex Jones is very
entertaining uh like you've got like all
these figures that and I think they
spread harmful ideas but like I'm
not gonna lie and say they're not funny
is how well they're doing it they're not
like super entertaining and then on our
side we just have like a bunch of like
people that are basically like
condescending and patreon to you and
it's like like it's just not a good
look
well that's a great Point yeah the way
the the foundational view that I have is
essentially is that like we've liked
that like one of the most dangerous
things in all of human history is we've
said that like the most educated man in
all of society has the exact same vote
as like a homeless dude both of their
opinions count for one vote in one
election and if we're gonna give
citizens the ability to go down and
equal to every other citizen decide to
vote on a leader that they want if we're
going to entrust the power into the
people to run essentially choose like
our elected officials how you now trust
them to talk about covet 19. that's
insane to me
hmm
yeah I don't disagree with you so what
are your thoughts then on the Rogan and
is it Peter Hotes yeah debate what do
you think about that I don't know have
you heard about that Graham I'm not
familiar so Rogan had on RFK Jr yes
recently and he was bringing up
skepticism towards the vaccine and
vaccine mandates and stuff like that and
then Peter Hotes skepticism right
skepticism or denying or whatever it may
be yeah um Peter I'm not super familiar
with the story Peter hotez goes and he
tweets him basically saying like oh like
why are you spreading all this I don't
know I think I saw some of that
misinformation or disinformation or
whatever yeah uh and then Rogan said I
would love to facilitate a debate
between you two and then Rogan said I'll
donate a hundred thousand dollars if I
can facilitate this debate on my podcast
and then hotels said oh Rogan that's
what you spend on a weekend hunting with
your boys like I know what the Spotify
deal with this you have a bunch of money
so 50 million is the the dollar amount
that I'm willing to actually agree to
Jesus absurd
um and then basically everyone's now
pitching in so you have like like
Twitter accounts that are like verified
check mark people like I don't know
maybe they're not even that credible
Mark Cuban who threw in like 100 Grand
no Mark Cuban uh is like Rogan why would
you ever platform you know what I'm
talking about yeah why would you ever
platform Mark Cuban came out like good
ass message yeah
of course RFK Jr because he's like very
pro-vaccine mandate and stuff like that
so anyways this whole debate's happening
everyone's trying to raise funding to
have this debate what do you think about
that this is a very big frustration that
I have
um when I have to argue against a lot of
these people I have to spend a lot of
time reading research reading studies
spending time on Wikipedia figuring out
like I've learned so much uh
because it's not my area of expertise
right and all this research that I'm
doing like all those everything every
time like a new Conspiracy Theory comes
out like I have to like do more reading
and more research to get like a handle
on like Immunology viruses like all this
I wish that people in the academic
world spent a little bit more time on
public Outreach because I don't think
that like the job should be left to
people like me to do it I my all of my
ability and bonuses and stats in life
are on this kind kind of like rhetorical
and argumentative side and I'm pretty
smart so I can do the research too but
God damn like rather than me who's
really good at debate trying to research
my way up there why not take a guy
that's really really well researched and
then haven't just like practiced a
little bit in terms of tomato
conversation I've seen the hotels guy
talk before and I don't think he would
be the good choice for that RFK debate
he seems pretty knowledgeable but he
doesn't handle himself very well in
conversations so I I wish that more
academics would practice that Outreach
because at the end of the day if
whatever you're studying in Academia you
know dies on the walls of your classroom
what's the point of anything you're
doing right you might believe all of
this and can prove all of it but nobody
in society does what value do you have
to anybody yeah that's very frustrating
to me so you think the debate should
happen I think the debate should happen
but you need to find academics you
shouldn't be hotels I I don't based on
I've only seen a little I've probably
watched like 30 minutes before arguing
based on a little bit I've seen he
doesn't seem like the kind of guy that
can aggressively handle himself in a
conversational situation a lot of the
times when you debate conservatives I've
noticed that you debate them very
aggressively do you think that it would
work in your favor if the end goal is to
actually convert
conservatives to having a more liberal
perspective would be to debate more
compassionately like you said how you
know if you slander someone are you
morally grandstand on them and you call
them a bigot that's not the best way of
converting people towards your ideology
do you think if you if you went into it
with more compassion that would actually
yield better results yeah I think so
it's funny that you ask me that question
because the research must have been on
relatively older videos because uh my
recent approach has been like very very
very compassionate usually the pushback
I get from my audience are other
people's and I'm way too nice to
conservatives like a lot of people call
me like a Nazi or a fascist or whatever
just because I'm I like try to be pretty
empathetic I don't understand when I'm
argue with conservatives and I tend to
do a pretty good job at that but my
relationship with people on the left is
so adversarial that like a lot of people
like oh you have no charity people on
the left you're so nice conservatives
and blah blah blah so why do people on
the left hate you there's something
called the big oh another biosite
cognitive bios something called the
bigotry of small differences
um if you're arguing with somebody that
is ideologically very different than you
there's not much they can say to
actually like hurt or upset you right
like if I'm talking to a conservative
and they say like oh like you support
the gay agenda and your blah blah blah
and I'm like okay maybe
um but if I'm disagree with a person on
the left their insults are like oh
you're racist you're homophobic you're
big at it and it's like no
um you feel a lot more strongly
um attacked by insults that are coming
from people that are more ideologically
similar to you because there's you don't
see yourself as the insults they're
giving whereas like for a conservative I
can understand a conservative saying
that like oh you're like a cuck sjw blah
blah it's like yeah to you I probably am
but like when a person allowed is saying
like you're a horrible racist person
that is like filled with hatred it's
like I'm absolutely not so I think for
people that are more ideologically
similar to you're more likely to fight
with them I think this happens to
conservatives and people on the left and
what was it that helped you pivot from
being more aggressive towards your
adversaries to a more compassionate I
think just strategy analysis over time
like when I in 2016 when I started
debating my whole kind of like shtick
was that I was like the aggressive
leftist debater that like no other
personal left was willing to do that but
just like over time as I talk to people
as I communicate to people say learn and
understand more about people I start to
realize that like if I change somebody's
mind to change somebody's mind to
understand where they're coming from
otherwise it's basically like I can come
into your audience and I just basically
on you and attack you so hard that
like some members of the audience like
think you did so bad that they kind of
want to like abandon you or I can step
in and be like listen I know you're
coming from like let's talk about this
or this and that seems to be a more
effective strategy overall to getting
people do you feel like your blue hair
helps or hurts you that's a really hard
one I like
I like to have a um I like to have a
wide scope in terms of like what I
present as and what I'm capable of so in
some ways it hurts me because it puts me
immediately on kind of like a back foot
because like oh you're a blue-haired
blah blah blah but then like it's also
funny to come on and be the blue haired
guy but like the other people are the
ones like screaming and losing their
mind and I'm like trying to be like
rational reasonable whatever so there's
like uh there's a big like dissonance
when somebody sees me and they're like
oh this guy's probably gonna come up and
scream about how we're all racist or
whatever but then like I'll come on and
make edgy jokes and like be chill or
whatever and so I think it helps a
little bit yeah I feel like a lot of
people on the right could completely
just ignore you miss you yeah because
they see like the beard or whatever they
see that just the destiny like your own
merch on your on your chest and then you
have a beard yeah the beard the beard
you know Jesus had a beard right can we
cut that the beard I guess we could the
beard is fine okay
the blue hair the blue hair maybe like
you know the beard is groomed pretty
well okay I'm not no that's all right
I'm gonna accept them piercings but you
know what I mean you presented yourself
a very professional way right rather
than what a lot of people view the
Liberals as do you think that it could
help convert also more people from the
right and it's also something different
it differentiates you I feel like from a
from just the stereotype that a lot of
the the conservative see and then that
would be enough of a shocker to
hopefully give them some space in their
brain where you can help them fill that
with something there's like of your idea
yeah there's a very delicate Balancing
Act between like how much do I wanna I
wanna say compromise but like how much
do I want to change my a demeanor about
me to appeal to somebody else versus
what ground do I want to fight over and
that's just like a subjective feeling
like every time
um
like I can either say like I'm gonna
dress on a suit in time be very
professional go talk to you um because I
don't even want to try to convince you
about appearance or anything or I can
say actually appearance is one of the
grounds that I do want to fight on I do
want to convince you of that I should be
able to talk to you you should be able
to hear me and as long as I'm making
good arguments and I'm having fun and
everybody's like being chill or whatever
even though I look a certain way it
shouldn't be a bother to you and
hopefully that like moves you a bit like
it moves the needle a bit unlike the
appearance thing but at the end of the
day just comes down to Ultimate like
what do you want to fight over you know
see I feel like your appearance helps
you with personal branding and online
marketing it absolutely does for that
because now so many people like oh my
God you're the blue-haired guy on Tick
Tock yeah exactly I've seen some of your
um interviews on whatever stands out
yeah it's there the blue hair but I feel
like when debating with certain people
they might dismiss you a little bit too
quickly because of that maybe yeah why
do you go on whatever I'm really good at
going into other environments and like
synergizing really well with especially
in hostile environments so I like going
on whatever because their audience is
like primed to hate me but I can still
go on have a good time get a whole new
audience to view me in a positive light
and then I like win fans in favor why do
they hate you because we're
ideologically completely different like
I like I hate almost every single thing
red pill people stand for
um and they're all tend to be like more
like conservative or anti-establishment
and Views so I'm like the exact opposite
too what are the biggest things you guys
Clash on though
well the last time I was there two days
ago was at a debate on abortion so that
was a but it was just me versus another
set of people um other times to like red
pill stuff basically everything my view
of like red pill is basically like red
pills hate women and then they try to
tell you all the ways you could
them over and that's like the entirety
of like the repo ideology that's what it
feels like to me
that's not like the best steel man
version but that's that's not really
frame it huh that's not how they no of
course not the way that they frame it is
through working on yourself yeah it's
male empowerment to put yourself in an
area where you have so much success and
power that you're able to attract and
Achieve whatever you want with whatever
woman you want essentially yeah so what
is your advice for a young single guy
out there if he wants to improve himself
he wants to get better at dating the um
oh it's such a complicated question this
is like it's gonna be this advice gonna
be so broad it's worthless but like my
advice is you need to find warm spaces
where you can have friendships and
conversations with women that is the
most important thing you can do if you
have no women in your life at all and
you're going to start trying to pick one
up on like Tinder or pick one up
publicly you don't even know how to talk
to a woman like start with warm spaces
where you can make friends with women
learn how to talk and not be
scared or afraid or whatever and then
like even you meet women through women
and you meet women in spaces with women
like from there you can kind of start to
build out you know like
yeah you're I guess like you're
eventually hopefully to get to dating or
whatever
um you can talk about like other things
people are like talking about like money
and looks and all that but um I
mean like there's plenty of guys that
that look really bad and don't have
any money because they just like they
put effort into it they try to do it and
there's plenty of guys with money that
look really good that way less than
people think so yeah what do you think
of what is a woman I thought it was a
really well done film I think it's very
convincing and I didn't watch the whole
thing yeah and what did you think about
Elon Musk pinning it as a tweet saying
every parent should watch this
screenline is the most cringe person in
the Universe you don't think
that every parent should watch it no why
not what what did you disagree with of
the documentary what is a woman the uh
well I disagree with the whole point of
the film obviously
um I think that the funny thing is that
I think that in a very roundabout way if
you engage with it like intellectually
the film makes a really good point but I
think it makes the point in the opposite
way that it thinks it does but anyways
like watch it normally they're gonna
come away like oh obviously a woman is
like an adult human female wife like
Matt Walsh's wife says in the end or
whatever
um
without getting into all this cringe
like theory of language stuff on a very
very basic level language is very very
complicated the way that we use words is
very complicated
um
I've argued with a friend for like two
days about what the word base means okay
language is very very very complicated
um the way that I view language is
typically when you say one word as soon
as you say that word there's a bunch of
peripheral things that kind of like
light up next to that word and you can
kind of like move through these
peripheral things but to define a word
exactly it's very challenging so like
for example we can take something very
very basic like a chair when I say chair
a whole bunch of things come to mind
immediately maybe the color brown maybe
wood maybe four legs maybe a back
there's a whole bunch of things but if I
try to say like exactly what is a chair
any and all of these things could
theoretically be up for debate right
like is a beanbag chair a chair
um is a chair with three legs a chair
obviously what about a chair with no
back what's the difference between a
chair and a table like that becomes like
for instance if I say chair and I say
table there's a lot of the same Concepts
let up right so broadly speaking that's
how we view language I think and that's
not a basic concept so when a
conservative walks in like what is a
woman like there's like some concrete
definitive answer gender is very very
complicated and I think that the best
answer on the show was actually given by
Jordan Peterson because when Matt Walsh
asked him what is a woman Jordan
Peterson's answer is relatively
insightful like I think he eventually he
ends up
um he says things like well maybe you'd
have a better chance looking at
temperament than like genitals or
temperament rather than gender and I
think at the very end he says I don't
think I don't even know if he knows this
is insightful as it was when he said it
he said I think he said if you want to
know what a woman is why don't you go
out and marry one and find out or
something which is actually How We Do
explore language you go out into the war
world you associate concepts with things
and that's how it goes so in that sense
sorry there's a big ramble like the the
film is interesting and that like Jordan
Peterson does actually give way more
nuanced responses than I would have
thought but Matt Walsh just like
announced his head and then at the end
his wife gives like the best answer but
um I just I I hate the topic because it
brushes over so many really complicated
aspects of how language and ontology and
categories are used and constructed and
how they exist just to try to like own
trans people which I think is really
dumb
um I think you can be like Pro or
against trans people but like at the
very least like treat like language with
the due respect it has but
yeah that was a yeah it's a good answer
yeah I actually think that makes a lot
of sense yeah what do you think about
Jordan Peterson
um Jordan Peterson is very smart and
insightful when he talks about
psychology and he's very stupid
when he talks about anything besides
psychology
so when he's talking about like politics
history social problems I just like it's
the worst thing ever when he talks about
psychology I think he's generally pretty
insightful but he doesn't seem to do
that as much anymore he seems like he's
on the politics he Roots a lot of his
political beliefs in Psychology maybe
like he relates everything back to
psychology yeah he tries to but like
it's hard to stretch he makes a yeah I
don't know let's talk about like the
cheese like he's even against like I
think like adults doing like trans
surgery now they didn't come out against
um Elliot page I think yeah like he's an
adult right um yeah I don't know Jordan
Peterson apologies is very sad it's like
listening to Elon Musk talk about
anything besides like I guess like
Aeronautics or startups or business or
whatever like when Elon Musk wants to
talk about like Ai and politics and
and it's like I don't think you have any
idea what you're talking about I don't
know why you think you should be talking
about this but
um but do you have any concerns about
what Matt Walsh is bringing up in the
documentary of like how we're making it
like putting it in public school systems
the books that are being shown to
children that are kind of not promoting
but kind of like
I mean in a sense
showing them something that maybe like
most parents wouldn't want their child
to be seeing at a public school I think
it's a really complicated question I
think you need a lot of data to figure
it out I think that trans stuff needs to
be handled very delicately in a research
medical setting and in a social setting
and I don't think either side wants to
handle it very delicately right now like
the left is like way too overbearing
with how they push it and they seem to
refuse the acknowledgment that any
amount of people could just be like
non-binary or whatever because their
friends are which is probably the case
especially in college
um and then people on the right are like
I think they I don't even know if they
think trans people exist anymore or they
just want to ban it completely or at
least for all children
um I think um I hate giving us like this
like both sides here to come together in
the middle it's not so much that it's
like what what people the problem is
like politically especially on LGBT
stuff people always Define themselves as
like the reaction to the other side it's
like on the left for a long time like
conservatives like we didn't want gay
marriage you know like stop all this
or whatever and so conservatives
were very anti-lgbt everything and then
progressives start to win a little bit
it's like okay well you guys are into
everything we're going to be like
pushing this as hard as possible and so
like now you know like even kids should
have access to transcript and then
conservatives be like okay well now
nobody should have it like this is
horrible we've corrupted Society uh you
know Michael Knowles like transgenderism
is a new religion that needs to go away
and and like everybody's just like
triggering the out of each other
and not actually trying to figure out
like what is like the most data driven
acceptable answer that we should have
can we accurately identify a kid as
who's trans if we can we should probably
give a medication for it if we can't we
should probably wait till they're a
little bit older like that should be
like a pretty simple why do you think
that the people are so fed up with or
not fed up but like focused on the
action of debate and being right versus
actually trying to solve the problem
do you think that these people think
that what they're doing is right or do
you think that they they probably think
what they're doing this right so you
think that they think they're acting in
good faith yeah but the problem is
generally people are people fight from
ideological platforms and the individual
policy issues are just like vectors for
them to spread their ideology like
that's literally it but they identify
with like a whole thing so they can
never change any of those individual
opinions like for instance if somebody
tells me that he's an Andrew Tate fan I
also know that 99 likely he's anti-vaxx
99 likely he thinks that the prior
election was stolen 99 likely he thinks
that like Bill Gates the world economic
forum and Klaus Schwab are trying to
control um probably doesn't think
climate change anthropomorphic climate
change is real probably uh Sports
Central like I know all these police are
the person I can't change their mind on
any of those beliefs because they're
bought into an entire system that
mandates strict adherence to every
single one of those things and to be
fair it's similar on the left too with
like a collection of beliefs as well but
like that so when any particular issue
comes up like I need to find out like if
I talk to somebody for instance and I'm
like oh like I think that like I think
we should mandate vaccine for children
in school like for a person that's
really broked into that Echo chamber to
that epistemic bubble that statement
that I just made that's an attack on
their entire ideology everything is tied
to everything else there is no way that
they can change their mind in one thing
because it's like a ball of yarn if you
unravel even a little bit of it it'll
all come apart completely because
everything relies on everything else the
vaccine has to be corrupt because Fouch
and the FDA are absolutely bought off
because the entire establishment is
completely rigged and that's why the
election was absolutely stolen for
Donald Trump and that's why the world
economic forum and all the people that
hit him publicly and then the world
stage are all against them because
they're all bonded like all of it is
like tied together and if one thing
comes undone then everything falls apart
so
so do you think that a big problem
nowadays is that people identify with
their perspectives or ideologies or
belief systems that they take that in as
a part of their identity and as soon as
the like it starts being attacked in any
shape form like they they just
completely implode yeah and then the
groups have gotten so big because of the
internet too like my guess is going to
be it's probably okay to have these
ideological divisions and groups if
they're happening at like really small
levels that's probably okay but when
they start to Encompass like hundreds of
millions of people then they become so
Broad and they Encompass so many
different ideas and beliefs that it
becomes impossible to uh it's just not
healthy for Society at that stage I
think
it's really interesting
makes sense
so what are your I mean I I guess I can
figure out assume your thoughts on
Andrew Tate
uh he's very funny I feel like I have a
lot of fun chatting with him uh chat
with them absolutely yeah
um I also think he's a sex trafficker
absolutely unless he's lied about the
things that he said if everything he
said is true on his YouTube videos and
everything then um but then he's also
said that what he said he was
exaggerating it's not true
um well he said that after he's gotten
he's contradicted after he's gotten
investigated and everything but like
he's laid out very specific instructions
on how to traffic women How to lure
women in how to cheat on their taxes uh
how to get them to work for you as a
proven no no this is just no no sorry
proven to be uh like good methods of
doing that yeah he gives he it's like
standard pimping 101 like everything he
says like very very standard like he
even uses some of the terminology like
he'll talk about like bringing a new
woman he'll bring in another woman that
he's been for a long time his
bottom he says these terms he'll
get that woman to convince the new woman
to do like kind of like sex work without
him actually saying anything so that
those two will go off and he'll have his
bottom convince her to get into
the trip like he like using these terms
using these words he's explaining
there's all of this yeah and then he's
even talked about like oh yeah like when
I'm doing taxes for these women I'm
supposed to pay them I think he says 50
50. I think he might say 50 50. but then
he says but he'll steal like 20 on the
taxes because women are too stupid on
these trades to do taxes and sometimes
if like if the woman says like well hold
on how much am I paying he'll like print
out some fake tax forms and give it to
them they're like okay I trust you and
he'll like have them sign fiction gonna
do it like he's talked in detail all of
that now it could all just be fake and
he's like lying and exaggerating it all
but if it is true he's obviously sex
driving but yeah but I'll rest it on
contention yeah you have said quite a
few things that were really interesting
because I see all the people or not all
the people I shouldn't generalize like
that but a vast majority of the people
on the left are like 100 he's guilty I
know he is and if he doesn't go to jail
the system's rigged but I did hear you
say that hey I'm not gonna really
comment until I wait for the uh for the
actual verdict of the trial uh but what
you just said
is not what I expected you to say based
off of what I had seen to say online I
think generally people jump to the
conclusions way too much absolutely
anything is is offered it's
automatically guilty otherwise why would
they even do this I think you gotta wait
you got to see until all the facts come
out I'm curious what you've seen them on
because I try really hard to qualify
that I I just watched it like like I was
I was eating lunch today and I I heard
you say like yeah you know I say what I
always say you gotta wait for the
verdict on the trial oh okay I thought
you were saying I said the opposite okay
gotcha yeah yeah the um but you just
said that you thought he was 100 guilty
if if what he says is true but that's
that's why the trial is important right
okay yeah one um this is a strategy that
I tell people sometimes to help you
change ideas is don't ever make an idea
part of yourself unless you know 100
free to be true always qualify what
you're saying so you can get away from
something if it ends up being incorrect
so for instance on the Android stuff I
don't know 100 I'm honest about that now
if I were to stake a whole bunch on like
he's absolutely guilty I know it
blah blah blah well if the court case if
the trial commences and either the
prosecution doesn't have evidence or
maybe the fact that maybe he didn't do
any of that things and then the trial
ends well now I'm in a really
uncomfortable spot because I tied a lot
of my stake a lot of conviction on this
idea I didn't qualify it at all and now
I either have to come out and say I was
completely wrong which undermines my
character a lot or what's more likely to
happen is I think oh the trial was
rigged right and this is what's going to
happen with all the prote people or the
anti-tape to people depending how the
drug goes right no matter what happens
one side can say oh it's clearly
rigged because they're so bought into
the narrative that either all of the
charges are fake and drummed up or that
he's 100 a traveler who's raped like
multiple women but if you qualify things
you're careful so like I've said this
over and over and over again
um he should go to court they should
have it in court if what he said is true
he's definitely a trafficker but maybe
he exaggerated it if they go to
coordinate fine and they find out like
they play the videos they do the
research and a lot of it was actually
just exaggerated or jumped up and they
didn't actually then it's very easy for
me to point back like Oh Hey listen I
said if they made it up then that's
always not true so yeah he's not a
trafficker and I can get off of that
very very easily so it saves me the
ability ability of having strong
conviction on ideas that I don't know
about and it saves my credibility and my
character and my self-respect because I
didn't like have to like either
backtrack or just double down on
something yeah I think that's super
smart and I also think that it's a huge
problem when people identify or they
turn their belief system into their
identity yeah yeah it's just it just
closes your mind entirely yeah because
then like an attack yeah I'm a person
that supports capitalism I'm not like a
capitalist I am a capitalist but like if
you show me something better
um I I like capitalism because I think
it does a lot of things really
efficiently but if you show me it
doesn't well then Capital personal
personal attack yeah exactly but for if
you have the more personal attachment to
your ideas than when somebody attacks
them they're not attacking the ideas
they're attacking your character and
that's not of your people don't realize
your characters never Up For Debate
nobody's gonna come up to a debate and
be like okay I might be a bad person
who's really stupid that's never gonna
happen so if you've internalized these
ideas so much that means that anytime
somebody attacks them it's a personal
attack and now you're fighting for your
life in a conversation because you don't
want to be wrong or stupid
is bad so what's your biggest insecurity
I don't have any insecurities you don't
have a single one no yes you do yeah you
don't have a single insecure something
man
I don't know man I feel like
insecurities are what it kind of make us
human in a sense I'm inhuman and I grew
up like relentlessly independent I mean
like I've got a lot to I can make I had
my dick pics I was streaming like two
days later I mean I'm a pretty scared
person there's nothing you're insecure
about so how how have you been able to
combat in security or was there a period
of time in your life just because of
like my the way that I grew up like I've
always been like highly internally
driven so if I'm doing something that's
not good or that I don't like I try to
analyze and change it and I'll move from
there
um but like like the way that I view it
is there's like a person that I want to
be there's an idealized version of
myself and I hope that I'm taking steps
towards that all the time and if I'm not
then I'm trying to change the path that
I'm on but um
I mean like in terms of insecurity I
guess if I do like really bad in the
debate or something like that sucks I
would feel bad about that but um
I'm probably scared of heights if I go
skydiving that probably yeah what's
worrying you today what are you most
worried about what am I most worried
about today
um
I don't know I guess probably like
managing my career going forward I'm
like at a very interesting Crossroads
where I'm trying to figure out like how
much of like do I want to be like
I don't know all the time like what my
role needs to be that's like something
I've thought about a lot and I'm
thinking about a lot of like the past
week or whatever as I'm traveling down
here is I don't know sometimes like
figuring out like how to deal with
people that are fighting with you online
figuring out like what kind of
Engagement should I have with people
like how respectful how disrespectful
um how staunchly should I advocate for
my ideals like should I be putting more
time into like research for doing like
intellectual debates
um should I be like trying to expand my
audience more am I working too hard am I
not working hard or not like I know
there's like a lot of stuff like that
and just like balancing career stuff
probably I'm sure you guys well yeah
from earlier today yeah you guys have
these things associated yeah that's
probably like the thing I'm I don't know
if I say I'm worried about it but
there's just like a lot of challenges
that always come up relating to that
kind of stuff where do you want to be in
five years from now I really want a
Media Company
um I've got all this to set up a
Studio I bought like all the
cameras all the equipment or whatever
I've got it like laid out I should just
set it up and start recording um I feel
like once I have a podcast I can kind of
grow it from there but like having a
media coming to be the coolest thing in
the world like I hate talking about what
everybody else is talking about it's fun
sometimes to like decide like this is
what we're going to talk about today and
then set like the discourse for stuff so
that would be like my I think you'd have
a crazy podcast maybe yeah hopefully
yeah that'll be really good I'd love to
see that so for the media company would
you just like to be like a daily wire I
think the daily wire is the best
template it's really good they've got a
lot of talent they do a lot with them
making films yeah they do yeah yeah and
it's very concise the way that they work
together and everything yeah good good
on Benny boy and everybody yeah they do
they run a tight ship so who would you
like to have on are there any other
streamers that we might know that you
would love to say like hey we'd love for
you to join this media company I don't
even know how we began to pick talent I
feel like the way that it would work is
I'd probably start my show and then I
would just kind of start looking at
other people and see if anybody but like
the first thing I have to do is got to
start my and then I'll probably go
from there and do it yeah I think it'd
be fantastic what do you think is the
biggest threat to humanity climate
change
um it's funny that's that was my answer
that's the biggest threat to humanity
um on a very broad sense I think the
splitting of us into these different
epistemic worlds where we have totally
different realities is like destroying
our ability to communicate with each
other and I worry if that continues to
happen and continues to accelerate
outwards that
um
I don't know if it would be civil war or
just like a total breakdown in
government because we can't pass any
legislation uh I think that that's
probably the biggest threat right now uh
what is it a nation divided against
itself cannot stand
um we have a really hard time working
with each other right now that's really
really really bad and I think that's
probably the biggest problem facing us
like when I look at the United States
during coven as soon as the United
States got its together in my
opinion I think one of the biggest
success stories of like capitalism and
American Ingenuity I know a lot of
people are triggered but I think it was
the manufacturing the MRNA viruses it
represented like the best of humanity
the best of globalism the best of the
world it was Pfizer an American
International Company working with
biotech German company that researching
for public research and private research
mRNA vaccines for 30 years once we
figured out like what was going on in
like eight months we had like a
revolutionary vaccine rolled out we
distributed what Biden I think came in
and wanted to do like 100 million doses
in a hundred days or something and he
did it in like 50 like everything was so
amazing when America is like like United
on an issue we have the capability to
like move heaven and earth like I think
the United States working as one joint
body trying to accomplish something can
do anything but we're so
schizophrenic on all of our right
now that we just can't come together and
agree on on anything because every
single issue is so politicized so yeah I
think that's I think the the divisions
we have amongst ourselves is the biggest
problem that we have right now yeah
it's a great answer that's probably one
of the best answers yeah I I agree with
that I'm kind of of the same type I
think it's just closed-mindedness in
general sure because I used to say it
was the media uh and then I thought it
was closed-mindedness and you think like
what causes Cloud mind it's
closed-mindedness and try to come to the
root of it but I think it's just being
close-minded I love that
um what do you think is the meaning of
life
um I've been working with a lot
um I think that there is some sense of
fulfillment to be found by working
together along other side along other
people at the things that you're really
good at
um so everybody has like a particular
set of like gifts and abilities I think
that we kind of owe it to ourselves and
decided to pursue this as much as
possible and then while doing that like
maximize your existence like a social
creature so family friends and all that
stuff it's like very very broad but that
might look differently for a lot of
people so say you're a person that's
like a really high aptitude for medicine
like for you like your fulfillment and
meaning in life might be you know being
the best doctor you can be giving as
much to society as you can getting that
like high level of personal fulfillment
because you're doing something for
yourself you're doing something for
other people hopefully you're going to
have a family stuff too you might be a
musician they can make like really cool
music you might be a streamer I guess
this is really cool streaming or
whatever but um yeah I think they're
like searching for some like really
broad sense of like fulfillment and then
trying to balance it out with all sorts
of like happiness right where
fulfillment is like that really deep
like I'm doing things that are above and
beyond myself versus society ready but
also doing things like keep me happy and
like motivated or whatever like finding
a balance between that and then working
social with everybody else is like on
the broadest level I think probably the
meaning of what you should be trying to
do and how filled are you like if you
were to give it a one to ten scale How
is how's everything going super lucky
I'm like a 9.5 for fulfillment like I
got to do like the coolest stuff like
every single day in my life like I'm the
most lucky person in the world
so yeah as an influencer how responsible
are you for the actions of your viewers
beliefs of your viewers and your
thoughts and your impact on your viewers
how much do you take this into
consideration when going live slash
voicing your opinion I think you have a
high level of responsibility
people might disagree on the level of
responsibility you have but at the very
least I wish that people would
acknowledge that you have a big impact
on your audience if I go out and I say a
certain thing for a long period of time
my audience is slowly going to start to
believe that and depending on the
opinion they're going to be certain
obvious answer uh actions that stem from
those beliefs so if I go on stream every
single day and I say I hate kids we need
to kill all kids I hate children blah
blah blah if like you know five years
from now people in my audience are to
like abuse children or like attack
children or whatever like it's pretty
immediately Downstream for the things
that I'm saying so I think that I think
that you like when uh parents used to
say you are who you hang around right or
garbage and garbage out ultimately oh
I've also heard that like you are your
five best friends like the summation of
their thoughts or whatever
um if I'm talking to people for eight
hours a day if I'm speaking a lot I'm
doing a lot the things that I'm saying I
know that slowly I'm going to change
their mind over time and they're slowly
going to believe me if they or they're
going to start to think things I think
so actions are reasonably going to stem
from those particular thoughts as well
so I would hope that the messages that
I'm putting out are encouraging actions
that I want to I want people to take
um and then yeah you ultimately I think
you're responsible for that now there's
some limitations there if you've got
like an audience of like 10 million and
one guy goes out and you know randomly
shoots up a school and you're like a
makeup streamer like you're probably not
responsible for that but if I'm telling
people over and over again like the
government's coming to take your guns
you know you got to be ready to fight we
gotta fight to keep our guns we gotta
fight for this like we can't live blah
blah blah blah blah and like you know
some number of my audience starts you
know like shoots up like a police
department or like shoots up like a
congress for a guy that's going to vote
on like anti-gun legislation I mean like
you're kind of like at the end of the
day like a lot of those thoughts might
be Downstream because I think I'm saying
so I try to be careful of that thank you
so much for coming on the ice coffee
hour really means a lot uh yeah it's
just like a really surreal experience to
meet you in real life cool it's been fun
yeah I loved it thank you so much we'll
link to all of your information Down
Below in the description cool